so neil young
threatens an ultimatum tells spotify
either me or joe rogan
and he stood firm good for him and
spotify said uh uh dude joe rogan and he
went oh and they remove they're gonna
remove all of his music so
congratulations neil you uh you have
lost this one but hey i gotta be honest
at least he's standing by his threats so
uh there you go thank goodness yeah
thank thank goodness that he's he's he's
standing up uh uh for what he believed
in uh you know what i got a bonus more
power to him if he wants to uh if he
wants to make a threat he stood by it
all right there's actually really big
news in fact it's uh is something wrong
something's wrong with the audio isn't
it
let's find out maybe there's something
wrong with the audio either way i'll
just keep talking um
supreme court justice breyer is going to
retire in my opinion this sends a huge a
very powerful signal democrats expect to
lose in november i think all the polling
shows this and and breyer is likely
retiring now so that they can nominate
someone and get them through before the
democrats lose the house and the senate
and that's the interesting thing losing
the senate too because we expect them to
lose the house we've got a 29th democrat
retiring very very interesting stuff so
we'll get into that and we're being
joined by tom fitton of judicial watch
and you can talk a lot about a lot of
the lawsuits you have one of which is
california requires you to have a woman
on the board or something like that yeah
if you're a public company you have to
have a corporate
uh there's a new rule that you have to
have a certain number of women on the
board
and what that means the mirror of that
is that if you're a man you can't apply
for certain board positions or be
considered for certain board positions
of public companies in california it's
outrageously illegal it's kind of
critical theory feminist style
so we sued on behalf of taxpayers in
california california has a liberal
taxpayer standing
law that allows taxpayers to challenge
illegal activity by government officials
oh interesting so you know we've been in
a
now six-week trial as the government has
come in and tried to make the case that
not only are they remedying
discrimination without having any
evidence of discrimination
but also that
making making sure that there's sex
discrimination and corporate boards
actually helps companies so it's a big
deal it's critical critical theory the
feminist version of it on trial
and the left is very concerned about it
because they have a new uh
a new law that followed up on that where
they expanded the required quotas uh to
your other protected classes uh uh
minorities uh sexual orientation and
things like that so there's a whole
quota system they've been pla they put
in place
to uh
make sure that boards are following what
they want to follow in terms of upending
uh
really
decades of anti-discrimination law so
you you guys do uh
a lot of lawsuits yeah do you want to
just give a brief introduction
introduction as to who you are what you
do well judicial watch is i run judicial
watch i'm president of judicial watch
and we are a um
nonprofit educational foundation and we
sue the government
mostly to get access information but we
represent people
whose uh rights have been violated we
help whistleblowers
and in the case like in california where
we sue government officials or
government agencies when they're
breaking the law
and
when it comes to uncovering government
corruption and here in d.c
we're second to none we've done more
than congress in the media and such so
it's really incredible work and i say
that not because i'm president of
judicial watch i just i just see
everything we're doing it's just
incredible
right on man well we've got a lot to
talk about so thanks for joining us we
got sheamus tonight no luke yeah no shim
cast is on tonight so luke went on down
to uh florida we miss him we love him
but i'm going to be filling in for him
for a little while until he's back and
it's great to be here and it's also
great to get a chance to meet you and i
think the work you're doing is fantastic
thank you i love your background i got
an audio product thank you yeah i think
tim might be kind of quiet no my mic is
completely off okay so we hear kim's
room tone um hopefully you know just
keep the comments coming and let us know
who sounds super chat tell us oh hey hey
there we go there we go tim's back
now
sorry about that so we will be i thought
i thought i thought i was doing
something wrong i'm getting all the
signals
everyone there's like people in the
background so no one can see this
because we're really good at it but when
like the camera's on sheamus i'm waving
my arm everywhere
my microphone is awesome
i'm like all right just keep listening
my microphone on now yeah yeah you sound
good
now i can hear you yeah i was like
what's happening i i couldn't hear
anything weird yeah and i'm like my
headphones off like what's going on
you know
we have the sound board we gotta upgrade
to pick up lyanna's yeah because when
like people noticed this we we started
the show one time and it was like static
yeah and it was really weird because it
should that that makes no sense why that
would happen but these things happen
welcome uh anyway i don't know did you
introduce yourself already no not yet i
mean crossland uh call me ian
crossland.net if you want to follow my
social media networks and um i'm i'm
happy to be here thank you hello tom
thanks for joining us and i am also here
in the corner trying to fix these sound
problems i don't know what's going on
over here i turned tim's mic all the way
off to get to try to work a little bit
brighter so hopefully you guys will let
me know if anything more is going on and
i will keep an eye on it yeah i think
your mic is off as well yeah i'm not
hearing yet yeah did someone come in and
turn all the mics off no i hear you
nothing is that better sneaky leprechaun
yeah wait why is it the leprechauns
ian immediately comes in with the
anti-irish race yeah yeah that's
actually the irish she's just like the
chicago fire blame the irish
fantastic kicked over german and irish
wait i thought they blamed the cow they
blamed miss o'leary's cow they had to
pick an irish woman like that the whole
city burns down they're like you know it
was probably an irish lady's cow yeah i
know down like come on we know what they
were doing
sure all right everybody let's get back
on track before we get started head over
to timcast.com become a member help
support our work as a member you'll get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
uh that we call the we call it the
uncensored segment because
we swear a lot
i mean i don't that's basically what we
do is like we're like it's uncensored
and people think they're getting like
secret information it's actually just us
cussing the whole time but uh no we do
talk about there's some subjects that
are obviously you know a little too
spicy for for youtube they would ban us
so we do try to have those conversations
on the website and as a member you're
just helping support all of our
journalists and don't forget to like
this video smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and let's jump into
the first story
you know oh we talk we talked about we
we talk about joe rogan too much we we
certainly do and i've acknowledged that
before and i guess the issue is
you know we're sitting down and we're
looking at all the news today we got the
story spotify to take down neil young's
music after his joe rogan ultimatum and
i'm sitting here and you know and i look
over at our good friend tom and i'm like
what's more important stephen breyer a
supreme court justice retiring or neil
young losing his battle with spotify to
get joe rogan banned and i i don't know
because i feel like the supreme court is
more important but you made a really
great point you said the the great
suppression is the biggest story or
something that affects yeah well that's
what we're in the midst of the great
suppression we have massive censorship
uh or an effort for censorship targeting
opposition to
whatever you want to call it the big
state uh deep state uh the communists
whoever you want to call it
and the communists are willing to use
multi-millionaires like
uh
neil young to suppress other successful
people like
but he lost yeah he lost and you know
but it's but rogan isn't the only one
being targeted it's his listeners being
targeted so when you take away a leading
voice that people look up to
and communicate and uses the basis for
further communications that's
suppression of all of rogan's audience
so whenever we're suppressed
all of our followers are suppressed and
harmed as well
it's the great suppression and it's not
private it's government it's private and
uh and it's corporate so we have a quote
here i guess this is from uh uh this is
from spotify they say
mr young's record label warner music uh
warner group corpse warner records
formally requested spotify remove his
music wednesday which would take several
hours to take effect across spotify
services across the world quote we want
all the world's music and audio content
to be available to spotify users with
that comes great responsibility in
balancing both safety for listeners and
freedom for creators spotify spokesman
said wednesday
we regret neil's decision to remove his
music from spotify but hope to welcome
him back soon now
the way the left is portraying this is
neil young stood for on his principles
and said i do not want to share a
platform with that man and so he took
his music down i see it as a big loss
because what his intent what he was
trying to do was he was like i'm neil
young yep you better ban joe rogan or
i'm out and they were like dude joe
rogan gets hundreds of millions of of
downloads per month and you get six
yeah you don't have any new music that's
like breaking the charts dude you're not
nicki minaj well that's the thing it's
that really embarrassing outdated rock
star ego like this isn't a convention
center where you can request you only
have green m m's in the bowl or you or
you throw a fit like joe rogan gets way
more views and downloads than him and i
don't know why neil young thought
himself in a position to determine what
we should be able to listen to but i
think it's kind of hilarious that spot
if i gave him the old okay boomer get
off our platform we don't care we don't
need you is he a boomer though he's 76
oh my gosh he's older than one well i
apologize i apologize for miss
generationing
but i'm telling you i'm glad i'm glad
his music's off no point because i think
it's great but is that boomer or is that
silent uh it's like 19 44. he's not 44.
he's a boomer yeah okay so i was right
tim boomer i was like 44 right 1944 is
when they began and it was silent up
until then i'm generation x
yeah and it's handled and boomer is
ahead of that well point is i think it's
a fantastic victory the fact that this
old school celebrity who thinks he's a
lot cooler and more relevant than he is
tried to throw his weight around and got
taken down is uh kind of incredible but
he's the oldest you can be to be a
boomer i just googled it says 76 68 to
76. and then technically it says you
could also be 58 to 70 to 67. there's
like two boomer generations i guess okay
so here's the no no no no that's silent
generation the world's oldest boomer
he's got booboo
spotify i'm about it ian
good i you know i think of neil young
he's always struck me as an angry dude
when i was a kid i used to look at his
face and be like why is he silent
generation i was right sheamus was wrong
well you were the silent generation
where the mic wasn't working earlier
big talk sheamus yeah so um
but this is this is uh uh
this is a big story it's it's
what i got out of this and i mentioned
this the other day is neil young this
protest guy
i thought he was supposed to be
protesting free speech right well he
said anti-war is his big thing i don't
think he's a free speech guy no the
anti-war movement was the free speech
movement he was part of that yeah and
now they're like oh speech is bad how
many warhawks has neil young tried to
protest being on the same platform as
he
did the story attacking mt he did the
song attacking mtv
for taking commercials or you know being
too corporate and he complained that the
mtv wouldn't play his song
so the irony of him trying to suppress
another you know artist
or sp another uh another person who has
a right a god-given right to share his
views
and you know this is a battle you know
it's embarrassing i think for the left
here but they don't they're never
embarrassed they don't stop because
normal people would be embarrassed
they're not they don't follow those
rules they they had the scientists who
weren't scientists try to
pressure to take him off they were
hoping to get a a ball rolling with with
neil young and something else they'll
keep on pushing rogan is a threat and
they're not going to stop but that's i i
don't i don't think zombies get get
embarrassed that they're eating brains
you know what i mean yeah yeah exactly
and they just yeah well isn't it
hilarious that they put together this
list of like 300 doctors who weren't
really doctors dentists yeah dentists
and they thought like that didn't work
so they're like we're busting out the
big guys we're gonna get nealy young to
try to take him down you're saying they
you think that people were encouraging
neil to do this yeah yeah the organized
left has they've been doing this for
years uh in terms of targeting um voices
they disagree with and
uh usually it's uh trying to
controversialize them to get commercials
off or advertisers office you know rush
limbaugh was
faced this years ago so it's you know
unfortunately there's nothing new under
the sun but it's gotten worse things
have metastasized in terms of
of uh the attack on speech and it's and
it's
you know my view is we're in a
revolutionary moment it's dangerous i
agree i agree but i will say following
this story uh i hope neil young will
remember that freedom-loving people
don't need them around anyhow love it
yeah beautiful i gotta tell you i i've
lived in georgia for the past couple
years and it's true a southern man don't
need him around anyhow i mean he
apologized for that apparently you know
when he got criticized for writing he
neil young wrote these two songs
criticizing the south and then he
actually
commented on it later being like yeah i
shouldn't have written those songs they
were they were too broad cancel culture
i want to i want to say real quick
the funniest thing about this story
is how the one person who's not talked
about it is joe rogan himself
like he doesn't care it doesn't involve
him he's minding his own business and
everyone else is like we're you know
we're sitting here waving our arms in
the air hooting and hollering like oh
and it's like i i just i imagine it's
just joe's like i i have a feeling i'd
call him and be like hey this neil young
thing and i'll be like what happened
yeah i'm like neil young they trying to
get you banned and he'd be like
i don't know what you're talking about
like oh well he doesn't care yeah that's
not right
the public policy implication that the
problem is you've got the media
celebrating it though yeah you know neil
young it's ridiculous as we're talking
about but the media kind of salivating
and celebrating the targeting of young
and you see
uh you know the cnn types and people
like that they love that this is
happening and so that's the dangerous
side of it you've got this whole media
political complex
along with big tech
that is excited about taking out
voices they don't like
well the ratings are in the gutter
their revenues are in the gutter yeah i
think i think we saw that turning point
for cnn when they lost their airport
contracts and all of a sudden i mean
that was what 95 of their viewership
yeah and i'm only half kidding to be
honest i don't think there's that much
right cnn's viewership was largely
airports and hotel lobbies yeah and then
they lost the airport deal that could be
a big reason why their ratings tanked
and just just you know but i don't know
if they actually count the airport stuff
in the ratings to be honest people
probably gonna be like no they don't do
that but they lost tremendous reach yeah
yeah they know they're losing it to joe
rogan among other people their
competitor and you know the dishonest
side of it is their competitors well
it's not even just politics it's a
business the businesses they're losing
viewers to people like rogan
and and you and frankly anyone else who
has a voice online that
normally isn't heard in cnn well and
that's what's so hilarious about the
entire situation you're absolutely right
people are looking at this as a matter
of politics and on some level it is but
what is very interesting is the fact
that he is direct competition for them
in the business that they're operating
in and so when they write these articles
about him it's literally people who work
for the companies that he's competing
with talking about how horrible he is
well of course they're going to say that
and what the media always does and what
the left always does
is as soon as they start losing they
immediately portray themselves as
martyrs and victims but the narrative
falls apart with rogan because he's one
guy who people really want to listen to
and they make it seem like he's this
reckless and irresponsible man who's
bullying them hey but isn't it crazy how
they've really ramped up the attacks on
joe rogan yeah like i was just reading a
story like some some attorney general
was saying joe rogan should be censored
who is that legit he's like they're
trump now yeah some some attorney
general was like that's biden's attorney
general he thinks it was biden's yeah
wow which would be sincere
the surgeon general came out and said
something about disinformation online i
don't know if he said specifically about
rogue yeah not the attorney general no
surgeon general yeah yeah yeah isn't
that like a man they're they're they've
lost control and
you know it makes me feel real good it's
great it's beautiful to see joe joe
we're going to have jordan peterson on
and oh boy are they all triggered well
culti leftists are like oh no and
they're lying it's so it's so hilarious
how like
dude
when you take a clip from joe's show
and then post it along with a quote that
joe did not say
you're a [ __ ] people anyone can watch
it right but and so when the people are
sharing it i see this clip where it's
like joe rogan said unless someone is
100 black you can't call them black and
i was like i'm gonna watch this clip and
joe said nothing of the sort
nothing of the sort literally just
making things up yeah i mean he some of
those things were like
tangentially related what he was talking
about he said it was basically strange
that there's like people from all over
the world of different skin tones and
different backgrounds and like just
calling all of them black just kind of
seems kind of weird because they're
different people from different you know
and i was like yeah you know like sure i
get what joe's trying to say but then to
take that claim
that joe's saying unless someone's 100
black you can't call them black i was
like why would they just lie about that
so when someone then retweets that i'm
just like these are not serious people
no you you it's good though because you
know they're just lying i don't think a
single person believes when they retweet
them like that and they're like oh look
at what joe said i'm like i know you
don't believe that yeah well cause like
you can listen to the guy and what joe
rogan is saying actually opens up a very
interesting discussion which is the fact
that in the united states of america
black people have a racial identity but
not an ethnic identity because of the
tragic history there and the fact that
they don't know which part of africa
they're from is individual people
whereas with the white population a
person generally knows if they're irish
german english dutch whatever ancestry
they have and there's some something
tragic there and it shapes the way that
a culture operates but of course the
media has to turn that into
joe rogan is racist and says you can't
call someone black unless they're 100
black it's ridiculous
well you know from the outside it looks
crazy the the self you know the identity
issues uh and and it sounds to me like
rogan was highlighting that it's like
well how do you calculate
who's one caller versus the other
especially since we now
envision people being able to
self-identify any way they want yeah and
you know uh
the left enjoys that they like that but
the downside of that is it's going to
blow up
the anti-discrimination infrastructure
we have here in the united states so if
you have laws that protect uh uh
women from being discriminated against
or you have laws that protect people
from being discriminated on the basis of
race if they self-identify in ways that
you know are kind of raise issues in
that regard well how are the laws
applied
and so there's this kind of war
on reality in some respects but also war
on the law in terms of discrimination
they they don't believe in these
anti-discrimination laws
because the way they talk and think
about them would would actually negate
them and make them inapplicable yeah i
think for me one thing that uh
you know instantly broke me out of the
left lies i just immediately saw it was
how
you know someone can identify as
whatever they want
as long as you agree with their
political ideology yeah like someone
super chatted us this the other day they
said
black people can't be racist but candace
owens is racist yes exactly okay hold on
there a minute because according to
their that makes no sense yeah but they
say it well for a marxist it makes
perfect sense yeah i mean that's how you
oppose it i mean that's communism
one-on-one she has false consciousness
and she's not black well i mean that's
that's communism well it's interesting
because the question i've always wanted
to ask they always pose this as a
question of black versus swipe and it's
like okay well like what if a black
person hates an asian person or what if
an asian person hates a black person or
a hispanic person hates a black person
like
if you're not white you can't be racist
so is that not racist what if an asian
person is black
the oh yeah i'm about to bend some minds
yo yeah people can't believe well what
if what if everyone in this room hates
an irishman well you guys all do based
on the way i'm treated it's not to be
fair and i've said this on the show
before and i know and i've said this on
the show before i know people who are
like actually born and raised in ireland
get upset when you say you're irish and
you've only lived in america but here's
the thing it's not like i'm not bragging
it's an admission all right it's just
like okay yes this is confession where
my ancestors are from
i'm kidding i'm proud of it but i'm
pretty sure everyone in this room is no
everyone's got some irish are you part
irish yes that's because the hand that
rocks the cradle rules the world baby
all right that's the truth
but but the other thing too is uh
i i find it hilarious when i see people
talking about me on you know like reddit
or something
and they're they say like people
like i don't know why people will be
like tim poole doesn't identify as white
or whatever and i'm just like i have no
idea what that means no dudes i don't
identify as white what does that mean i
don't know what that means yeah it's
supposed to be your skin color but it's
not no one's white no one has white skin
it's crazy but
look
wait either the left social justice
marxist cult or whatever doesn't view
race
as skin color they view race as
political then later
depending on like the man this is what
they do
in order to win an argument they'll use
they have two different paths they can
take with the same language
so they can say no i'm not talking about
politics i'm talking about how someone
can look at this men discriminate
against them and then later they'll be
like i'm not talking about skincare i'm
talking about the politics of blackness
the political black it's like okay dude
you're talking about whatever gets you
power exactly
well and this is the thing i mean
when they talk about being white or
identifying as white
they fail to take into account how an
individual person actually identifies
themselves and so i understand their
argument that because i'm white i don't
really think about my skin color etc but
if you look culturally at my you know
upbringing being from an irish catholic
home in the chicago area and you compare
that to the upbringing of a white dutch
person or a white english person who was
raised in a protestant home or without
religion you'd actually find and i have
found this
just based on the churches i've been to
throughout my life is that i have far
more in common with a person on the
basis of what religion they were raised
in as as opposed to their skin color and
so when you're you're talking to a black
person or a mexican person who was
raised in a catholic household you can
just relate on a level that i don't
relate to on somebody just because just
because they're white it's ridiculous
like that's not how i identify i have
more common with people that like play
blue and magic the gathering then
they're [ __ ] their skin color i don't
care about it uh it was uh matt walsh
made this point about uh when it's on dr
phil he said we can dig up a skeleton
hundreds of years later we can't know
what they were thinking but we can know
it's you know male or female or whatever
and i think that that actually says a
lot more than just that conversation
it's it's like you are so much more
as to who you are on the inside your
values the things you believe than what
you look like you know what i mean and
it's such a funny thing i joke about
this but like in the united states irish
people were not like considered white
until being white meant you had to
apologize for being white
well there you go yeah congratulations
no i know but no it's just interesting
because like whiteness is a label that
was actually used to bludgeon my
ancestors so when you look at who was
excluded from the united states and the
people who had a light skin tone who
were considered non-white it was almost
always catholic groups
and what's frustrating to me is that
we're having this conversation and
it's one thing to have the conversation
it's another thing to be in positions
where you're in a school and you're a
teacher
or you're in government and you're being
told
you are a bad person because of the
color of your skin
so the crt or whatever you want to call
it the the
the the woke uh approach it's not just
about it's offensive morally and
intellectually yeah as applied it's
illegal
okay you're not supposed to discriminate
on the basis of race and select people
on the basis of race i mean we we just
had settled a lawsuit
in asheville north carolina they had a
scholarship program
only black kids could apply
completely outrageous yeah that's insane
so we filed a civil rights claim against
them and they settled and they changed
the rules so that it's you know i don't
know it's race neutral well so let me
ask you but but it's but they're trying
to undo
constitutional protections of equal
protection of the law and the civil
rights laws of the 60s they're trying to
do it we're trying to defend it and i
don't mean us judicial watch we are
literally but i mean us who are
conservatives and follow the rule of law
we actually believe in
non-discrimination they don't isn't that
crazy how they flip the script on you
guys we're civil we're the civil rights
advocates the craziest thing to me was
this past election when we had
california trying to repeal the civil
rights language from their constitution
did you see that one
it was it was they called it the
affirmative action amendment it was such
a sleazy title for a bill it literally
would just strip out from the california
constitution the language says you
cannot discriminate on the basis of race
you know sex uh sexuality or origin or
whatever in public accommodation or no
in public employment contracting and
schooling or something like that and
they were like we need to get rid of
this so that we can be fair and treat
minorities fair and unlike when we
we fought for civil rights in this
country to make sure the law would not
take these factors into an into account
and now the left is trying to repeal
that language in california they lost by
the way
but i remember you know i've told you
guys the story before but those who
haven't heard it i was talking to a
friend of mine an activist a prominent
you know well-known celebrity in in in
hollywood and we're having a
conversation because we've been drifting
apart politically and i said
what's the what's the what's the you
know the racial makeup of california and
it's like 70 was it 70 white or
something like that and i said
so if do you think that when california
repeals their non-discrimination
language from the constitution that the
70 white majority is going to protect
the minorities now or do you think
they'll just either consciously or
unconsciously start benefiting
themselves and their race
and and there's there's no real answer i
get from these people
because they don't want to admit they're
wrong in repealing this language because
it's part of their tribe
but i was like look some of these cities
in california are like 99 white
and if your perspective is that white
people are racist why would you empower
these people to discriminate on the
basis of race and they have no answer
they have none now i gotta be honest i
don't really think white people in
california are gonna be like ah now's
our chance to be racist yeah
but if that's their ideology why would
they want to repeal that language unless
they actually want to be racist and they
actually want to do these things yeah
exactly well because these white people
aren't going to be like i can like
oppress other people who are not in
white but they could go i'm going to
make myself feel better about this white
guilt complex by a pr like
discriminating against white people i
don't i gotta be honest
i i really think that what we're dealing
with in the culture war stems largely
from those in the know and those who
aren't that's really it i mean if you if
you go to i went to the uh march for our
march for our lives i think it was that
was the gun thing and i saw all these
people holding up signs saying ban
assault weapons or whatever right and
i'd ask them like you know what does
that mean yeah and they they couldn't
tell me and i there are several people
that said you know uh assault rifles
should be illegal or should be you know
like ban assault rifles and so i'd stop
and i'd talk to people and i'd be like i
wanted to ask you about your son and i
said uh so you want to ban assault
rifles and they'd be like yeah and i'd
be like
well they're almost entirely banned you
can't make any new ones i think since
1984. and in order to get one now it
requires you know a special licensing to
take take up to a year the tax yeah the
tax they're typically very expensive
they can be thousands of dollars and
they would go oh i didn't know that i'm
like what are you protesting i wasn't
mean any i was just like okay i had one
woman she was holding up a sign and i
asked her these questions and then she
folded it up and you're like oh i didn't
know
i'm like then what are you protesting
so i i genuinely believe a lot of these
people just don't know so
this activist friend of mine
posted something recently from the march
for life you know sheamus you were down
there yes and it was some like lefty guy
walking up to protesters and saying how
many children have you adopted
and it was like this bumbling
middle-aged woman she goes none and he
goes oh okay i've adopted two and she
goes great and then he goes another how
many of you adopted and she's like i've
not adopted any kids and he's like i've
adopted two it's like okay
and i'm watching this and i'm like what
message
is my friend trying to convey with this
that these two women haven't adopted any
children
most people don't adopt children is this
an indictment of the pro-life movement
yeah they just don't know if they went
down there and they spoke to any of the
organizers they'd be like oh
look a lot of the organizers a lot of
people involved do run charities for
helping children and promoting adoption
and they do adopt a whole lot but they
just don't know anything about this
why
well i think
apathy
a lot of people just don't care they
want to pretend to care it makes them
look good on social media right yep
general ignorance it's not their jobs to
be journalists you know i don't blame
every single person for just not knowing
some people look you work your nine to
five you go home you got you want to be
with your kids you want to play maybe
you throw throw a football a little bit
you don't got time to sit down and read
all this stuff yeah and but i will blame
the mainstream press to to a great
degree let me pull up the story we got
from uh from fox news
cnn's jim acosta compares virginia to
soviet-style police state under glenn
younkin
critics took to social media to blast a
cost as comparison calling it a bridge
too far and evil well as you as you all
uh may not be aware jim acosta is doing
some show on cnn called democracy in
peril i think it's funny that glenn
younkin only just got into office
there's no soviet-style police of
anything nothing's barely anything's
happening meanwhile in dc you need to
show your papers to get into a
restaurant yeah exactly but not but not
to vote
not to vote so the question what what
exactly does it cost to think the
parallel is here he's lying yeah you
know and and i don't know if he's in new
york or atlanta or dc but
in our nation's capital
if you want to visit the capitol and
protest it's more difficult to do so
especially if you're not vaccinated if
you want to communicate with your
elected representatives it's nearly
impossible to do so we have that rump
committee
threatening and talking about throwing
out hundreds of members of congress
because they opposed
the um they were involved in the
election disputes you have the justice
department talking about investigating
thousands of people because they were
opposed to the election disputes that's
the soviet-style approach to governance
you see joe walsh good for you on
twitter
no i know who he is i didn't see it he
said anybody who tries to put forth a
fake group of electors should be
investigated or blah blah blah so so let
me just which democrats did in nineteen
sixty people why that's right so what
they made up a fake story rachel maddow
talks about it she's like i've
discovered
forgery documents they're shut up
they're not forgeries what happened was
when the election was being contested
whatever your opinion is is not the
point
republicans said we are going to fill
out the forms the same as the democrats
were and we're going to submit them and
sure enough when the official electors
came in and were certified for the
democrats they went and pence chose them
and it was 1960 i believe right yeah
nixon versus kennedy
hawaii certified republican electors but
the democrats decided to go and and fill
out their own forms anyway
lo and behold the courts ruled in their
favor so when the uncertified
democrat electors went to to the joint
session of congress nixon said we know
what happened the courts have ruled so
i'm gonna pick these anyway
imagine that it's historical precedent
but now you've got these lot these
people lying about it and that's what i
say this is why i say the the the
culture war is between people who know
and people who don't know because if
you've read i read about that stuff in
1960 years ago with with nixon i was
reading it years ago and you know with
the midterm elections or whatever and so
when all this stuff comes up i'm like oh
yeah they just did what happened in 1960
but you know media lies about it yeah
yeah i mean my view there's a special
place in hell for politicians
uh who want to
[Music]
put their political opponents in jail i
mean to me that is a particularly grave
evil should be a donald trump jail for
him donald trump said hillary clinton
should be in jail well i don't think
he's he said she should be he should be
processed she should be prosecuted and
she didn't he didn't want to put her in
jail because she didn't he didn't like
her politics he thought he commit she
committed crimes here you have the
leftist saying
oh participating under the first
amendment and a rally is an evidence of
a crime participating under the
constitutional system to challenge
electors and federal law to challenge
electors that we've done since time
immemorial that all of a sudden is a
crime right it's it's more pernicious
than that it's one thing to say i think
this person committed a crime
she stole all her emails i mean we were
involved in that it's another thing to
say i don't like your politics and you
should be censored and you're a criminal
and a terrorist that's what they're
saying
in a casual way yeah also i want to
mention this i mean the um the the
clinton campaign wanted to have us
intelligence officials brief the
electoral college on russian
interference in order to sway them so
they i mean they have absolutely no
respect for the system or ensuring that
the electorate or those in the electoral
college select those who were voted for
we went through
five years yeah technically now it's
seven years but i was you know before uh
in 2020 had been five years of lies
about russia and ukraine and all of that
manipulation you want to talk hey jim
jim you want to talk about soviet-style
police state let's talk about how
some dude who works for the cia accuses
the president of some nonsense and the
people of this country can't even say
his name please don't say his name
because we can't because uh you want to
know who's who's enforcing the
soviet-style police state it is uh the
democratic establishment it is the media
is social media if we say the name of
this guy youtube will take the stream
down well and that's exactly the thing
so i think the best way to summarize a
soviet-style system and the perils in
america are as follows in 2016 it was
alleged that the election was fraudulent
and in that instance we investigated
those who were elected
in 2020 it was also alleged that the
election was fraudulent this time we
investigated the people making the
accusation yeah othello isn't doing this
since
68 they thought nixon stole the election
they had secret negotiations with
vietnam
72 he overwhelmingly won
so the left used watergate to relitigate
he cheated his way in 1980 reagan had
secret talks with iran his his election
was invalid
i saw this i think snopes tried doing a
fact check on it but it said something
like uh every election since 1968 the
democrats have claimed has been stolen
is that well i it's at 72 000 i was down
counting dallas in 2000 wow gore was
running around trying to change the
results
and then uh 2000 uh well then now we're
in 2016
with the uh with trump
they tried to change they tried to
change the results i'm just
i'm just tired of it um i gotta be
honest i'm tired of it with the trump
supporters to be honest i'm tired of it
i've been tired of it from before this
it's just
look i just want to get to the point
where
we move forward
but i think we need to understand at
this point
2016 2020
2068 whatever year i don't care
nobody's playing by the rules anymore
and i mean that figuratively and
somewhat literally what i mean is it's
like you know walsh on twitter being
like we should lock up the people forged
these documents but they didn't that's a
lie
when they subpoena alex jones
these subpoenas from the january sex
committee we had i think i think bannon
may have told us this expensive
you can't just get subpoenaed and be
like okay tell me where to go yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's cash they said it's
fifteen thousand dollars to look at it
to just to look at yeah yep and so what
they're doing is they're draining
resources they're using the power of the
federal government to to uh suppress to
shut down
dissonance the weight of the government
is going after political rivals in a way
donald trump never did the man talked
big and said to hillary oh you'd be in
jail and then did nothing yeah yeah he
did nothing did you see the politico
story the other day that confirmed or
showed that the capitol hill police
department which answers now to pelosi
and schumer pelosi is the queen of the
hill when it comes to security is
gathering intelligence on members
under the guise of security
investigating where they're going who
they're meeting with donors and staff
so you've got this unholy melding of a
police force with a political party i
bet that they're thinking if we don't
observe and spy on everyone the chinese
ccp is going to do it so we have to take
we have to be the ultimate spy network i
think that's the mentality well many of
them are on the payroll
oh yeah so it's bigger than the
governments and it's more of a
multinational coercive yeah i would get
down with that i do think we're winning
you know the the like the raid on
on james o'keefe it just shows you how
completely desperate the establishment
is to maintain their their their power
now that was a wild abuse of power and
uh we just got documents last week i
don't know if you saw that's right the
pfizer stuff i mean we was james talking
about was he on with you recently
talking about it yeah he was on but i
don't think he i don't think we talked
about it so we was like right afterwards
this was fun because sometimes when they
tell you no you learn something
so we asked the fbi give us records
about communications with pfizer about
project veritas
and they said we can't give you those
because they're in an investigative file
oh confirming their existence normally
they don't confirm it so it was kind of
an odd response yeah so they've
confirmed that pfizer is with working
with the fbi somehow to target project
veritas
who had for those who don't know had
done some expose on
fetal stem cells fetal cells and being
involved or fetal organs being involved
in the
creation and
helping guarantee the safety of vaccines
things that they didn't want out there
which are true
but they don't like it out there because
people get upset about it but that's
just the veritas thing is a really good
example of the desperation
to be to be that overt with your
strategies to go against american
journalists it just shows
to use the metaphor we've used non-stop
for the past two weeks the emperor has
no clothes
but they had they had power for a long
time and it's it's being ripped from
them i think the internet is is what's
causing it yeah well it's just at this
point imagine trusting a journalist who
the entire system isn't trying to crush
yeah when uh uh
any news channel that puts on adam
schiff i'm just immediately like okay
it's fake news yeah exactly off exactly
nancy pelosi too
i mean i think it's fair to to bring
those people on if you're if you're
adversarial but you want to make fun of
them you know yeah i don't know i
i'm all big part of like ban the account
not the person i don't think that just
because someone has a track record of
lying that they're necessarily lying so
i don't want to discount these people
flat out i understand that there's maybe
it's more of a variance scale and maybe
someone that lies a lot is like maybe a
seven percent weight to their statement
but that's still seven percent
i don't know man so you're right that it
is technically possible for somebody to
lie about something and then tell the
truth later on but a person loses their
credibility and honestly there are so
many people trying to compete for our
bandwidth that i have no interest in
giving my attention to someone who i
know has lied before you know with
politics
you don't repeatedly i don't really care
whether someone lies too much in
politics i mean it's a problem you know
morally it's objectionable as a voter
it's the corruption that bothers me
adam schiff
abused his power to take the phone
records of rudy giuliani and publish
them and then we go to court trying to
get the records and part of their
argument was we can do that we don't
need a court authorization authorization
to do it so right now we know that
they're taking the phone records of
people and who knows internet records
and potentially i don't know millions of
people the way they're awarding these
requests
and there's no control or public
policing of it yeah you know that's an
abuse of power that's corrupt it's not
even they're even using subpoenas
anymore they're just requesting the
information so if you're if you were a
supporter of trump online and made
comments on election and you had your
account deleted or censored that's the
sort of stuff that congress is asking
for information on i mean do you want
that in the hands of congress or adam
schiff these are like i keep on saying
these are our republic is under assaults
and and this isn't political differences
this is a question of whether or not
we're going to follow the law and we're
going to follow the constitution the
infrastructure the constitution is laid
out for us and how we govern ourselves
or whether the bad guys are just going
to break all the rules to go after their
enemies they change the law uh the
patriot acts insane but they made that
legal so that now they can legally just
take all the records legally even though
it's still corrupt well yeah i mean the
fbi hasn't backed off from their
targeting of parents as terrorists i
mean there was controversy about it but
they're still doing it yeah
let's talk about this story we got here
from timcast.com supreme court justice
stephen breyer to retire
the justice and the bite administration
have not yet released a formal statement
gensake did say you know it's the
prerogative of the of the justice to
retire when they feel like it but uh i
mean that's the story stephen breyer is
going to stay until the end of the term
which just is uh when is that ending is
that ending in october i mean they
usually end the term in june sometimes
july but normally all the decisions are
done by the end of june oh okay june
june yeah all right so um
seems to me
that breyer who is considered a liberal
justice they're doing this because they
think they're going to be losing the
midterms
yeah they force briar out the left had
this really unprecedented campaign to
pressure biden excuse me to pressure
breyer to retire i guess there's another
campaign to pressure biden to retire
that's coming from all sides to be
honest uh but uh and breyer
had some interviews late last year or he
was out i think selling a book or he was
being interviewed and it was pretty
clear he had no interest in retiring and
something changed and they pressured him
and he left they bullied him off the
court
and you can bet the left that bullied a
sitting supreme court justice off the
court is going to demand that biden
point a appoint an extremist to replace
him not a not a normal liberal someone
who's extreme well and and so that's
going to be the battle and you know uh
technically senate you know the senate
can get someone passed for biden or
confirmed by biden
if they get 50 plus one vote and we'll
see what happens and kamala would be the
tiebreaker i'd imagine we're going to
need trump unless she's the nominee if
we're going to save
and if if we undercover but then lindsay
lindsey graham would vote for yeah
lindsey graham has voted for most of the
uh
judges put forward by biden at least in
in committing yeah like you were saying
how canceled culture can whip up a
frenzy so quick now it's like things can
happen so fast that
having someone in power for 50 years as
a supreme court justice is too dangerous
it doesn't make any sense anymore i
think we need term limits otherwise
we're going to get a 38 year old or a 42
year old that's going to think they're
going to be in power for 50 years
and then
i don't know you know i thought about
this an interesting question that you
know should we have a time limit for
justices or should it be a lifetime
appointment there's pros and cons
i do like the idea that you know when
someone gets appointed it kind of puts a
pin in the cultural perspective and says
like you know this person he's 45 he's
going to be a justice and he's going to
be there for 40 years it kind of helps i
think it's a stabilizing force
the the detriment however is you get
someone like you know we had the supreme
court justice who was on his you know he
was partially comatose or whatever and
he was just like shaking in his bed and
they're like what do we do well he's a
lifetime appointment so right but i
don't know what what do you think you
think we should boot them out at a
certain age or something or you know i'm
sympathetic to that uh that i think the
most the chief concern is the quality of
the judge and his judicial philosophy so
having a judicial supremacists on the
court who wants to steal our liberty and
steal our self-governance and govern
from the bench if he's on the court for
a year that doesn't do us any good if
he's on the court for 10 years it
doesn't do any good but to have someone
who defers to the constitution and
applies it as written and originally
understood
you know having them on the court for 30
years is fine the question is what is
the role of the court in our
constitutional system and it is that
it's outsized
you know we shouldn't be waiting waiting
with baited breath about how we're going
to govern ourselves on these core issues
every june
what's the court going to rule you know
the court is one branch of our
government and
i'm against judicial supremacy and that
should be the big fight and i i would
expect that finally at least republicans
who share those views you know we can't
be approving
judges just because the president
deserves there's his justice no no no
the people deserve to have their rights
protected and not violated by justices
who think they know better than elected
representatives amen this this is this
is there are several uh laws and and
there's several rulings you go back they
just seem to be out right wrong
just on the face
um i think
well
i'll i'll throw this one to you seamus
roe v wade yeah absolutely because the
big argument and and uh is that it
should be a legislative issue not a
court issue the court shouldn't be
legislating right
so break this down for me though i'm
just trying to highlight the issue
without getting too political on it but
uh the the big argument that we heard
from you know kavanaugh i think clarence
thomas uh when they were arguing the
mississippi abortion law they were like
why is this a court issue on a
legislative issue
well when you re and i encourage people
to read supreme court opinions because
they're generally written for public
consumption and if you're you know
literate you can understand them
and the left is exposed when their
arguments are uh laid out there and when
you read rural versus wade you see it's
written like a piece of legislation it's
a perfect example of legislating from
the bench
and it's not appropriate
abortion has been regulated by the
states
you know for most of modern history you
know until you know certainly once law
once they started talking about abortion
they were regulating and restricting it
i know there's arguments about the
history but it was a medical procedure
and it was regulated and there was no
federal jurisdiction over
making sure that abortion was in the con
of protecting the abortion right it's
not part of the constitution
and and so you had the courts
uh certain courts uh in the supreme
court justices who
[Music]
agreed that women should have the right
to abortion and then they mistake they
mistook their policy preference for what
the constitution
requires and i talked about
you know i remember seeing judge pork
you know lose his nomination
and he wrote a book he called it the
tempting of america and the great
tempting for
the great temptation for judges is to
get on the bench
and impose your political views and call
it jurisprudence
so we one day after the show here a
while ago now almost a year and a half
ago
one of our friends back at the old
studio uh nishra who's uh adam's wife
she
we we're all hanging out in the kitchen
and she's she's from sweden so she says
i have a question the your constitution
it says the right to keep in bear arms
shall not be infringed and i'm like
right and she's like well why are they
banning guns and everyone starts
laughing just because it's like
someone who doesn't live in this country
could clearly see how broken the system
is
and that it makes no sense and we all
laugh because we know
we we know that let's just legislating
from the bench
uh and not and and not uh
you know the courts not properly ruling
on our rights it happens all the time
the system just seems
it feels like we start with a good
foundation and now it's just like this
wonky jenga tower of random blocks stuck
in places because people wanted to you
know get something for themselves well
on the other hand things are going well
that's why the left is so upset about
the supreme court and they want to
expand it you had last week
you know you had nina totenberg defame
and smear judge gorsuch jane mayer of
the new yorker went after justice thomas
and his wife afterwards you're going
after his wife to get at justice thomas
you've had this pressure campaign on
breyer and i keep on talking about all
our institutions being under assault
they're trying to blow up the supreme
court
uh with this court packing scheme so
that briar
breyer leaving is you know he's he's a
liberal he'll probably be replaced with
a liberal but the goal is to pack the
court and negate the conservative voices
on the court that now are rising and
dominating yeah i mean
the i think the populist view is that
roberts is not
conservative and that you know uh
kavanaugh hasn't actually done a pretty
decent job or anything like that but i
don't think they're going to place briar
with a liberal i think they're going to
replace him with a marxist or something
like that
yeah well we'll see what uh senator
manchin has to say about it yeah but i i
you know yes mansion and maybe cinema
because they've they've stood you know
they've you know resisted the democratic
party's whims
but you still have some republicans who
are going to be like now now we got to
be accommodating and fair
but it's an election year so so i think
uh
it will be
there's a greater chance that
republicans will be unified against a
extremist nominee and it depends who the
nominee is
well biden says it's going to be a black
woman
well again
so now joe biden has announced that no
male need apply no white person need
apply yeah how is that legal can you
guys i mean would you guys sue him over
that i don't think you can sue him over
that i don't think so
but that's i mean it's it's so weird
that we're at this point in this country
i mean i always want to sue over
everything and yeah and the lawyers say
well you can but you won't succeed yeah
you know what the saying is you can sue
a ham sandwich another world leader that
uh was obsessed with appointing um a
specific kind of creature to uh the
their role was uh caligula who appointed
uh the roman emperor the inbred roman
emperor who appointed his horse to be a
chancellor uh when you but it wasn't
that he was insulting them yeah he was
like making a mockery of the system but
this is different also yeah this is
racial identitarianism it's insanity our
presence it's for our supreme court well
it's the same thing with his vp nominee
and it's hilarious because
he chose kamala harris essentially to
pander to progressives because he
pigeonholed himself he said i have to
pick a woman of color and basically
every progressive i know hates kamala
harris so it's beautiful and i can only
hope that they will hate his supreme
court nominee just as much but of course
i'm sure that i don't like them either
the way the democratic party has been
going in the past couple of years i
wouldn't be surprised if biden chooses
the most absurd
hated person neo-liberal establishment
and all the progressives start screaming
and then the democratic senators are
like if i vote for this i'm going to
lose so
i mean whoever he picks like it is going
to be horrible it's going to be a
horrible thing
whoever he picks like we're waiting for
daddy to make a move it's so gross how
does this one dude get to pick it's
called the president they're gonna make
the decisions the constitution gives
them the right to appoint the job and
the senate has to provide consent and so
an advice and consent is the term is
so there is a there is a check in place
and it's going to be close run thing i
mean typically
you know if mitch if mitch mcconnell
were in the majority there'd be no doubt
the nominee would get through
my view is chuck schumer has been an
awful leader for the democrats uh he's
been dragged around by aoc and the left
and he's lost control of the senate and
so i i think the president's nominee
that otherwise might be able to squeak
through might be stopped because of of
the craziness in our politics right now
let's talk about this story we got from
the la times
trial to determine if requiring women on
boards is legal that's our truck so this
is your trial this is a story from uh
back in december but uh you know when
you get a president who says
the principal determinant for a supreme
court nominee is going to be race and
gender i'm like that flies in the face
of the civil rights movement it flies in
the face of what we were fighting for
and it's what the critical race
theorists want to the the cultural left
or whatever they want
your position to be determined
determined based on identity
so you so in in california what did they
do they passed a law saying that
the legislature passed the law requiring
certain that a certain number of seats
be
a set aside for women
and so that means that men can't apply
for certain seats on corporate boards of
directors in california
it's outrageously illegal it's a
violation of california constitution
which is even has more broader
protections
uh for against sexual discrimination
than the federal constitution does
and so we've been in court we have four
lawyers out there for six weeks
fighting the government who are bringing
in all these
uh all these so-called experts who are
pretending that it's right to require
women to be on the boards and and
discriminate on the basis of sex and the
argument they're using the left argument
is well it helps corporations to have
more women on the boards you know
there's no real evidence of that but
even if it did it's illegal it's still
illegal it's still legal and but the
point is they're fighting it and so
those of us who
when the left says they're in favor of
and hate discrimination
that's the big lie of our error yeah the
the
the most interesting development and
troubling development is the the
thorough assault
on anti-discrimination law in our
schools and our corporations and our
military
and uh you see it now in the government
that that you can target people based on
race or sex and discriminate against
them and you'll have all the king's
horses and all king's men i mean we're
in court suing the california state of
california where is the justice
department
where is the justice department the
civil rights division is harassing
states for requiring voter id but
allowing discrimination
based on sex race and every other
category to go on in california with
nary a peep
yeah was trump doing anything about it
listen for trump well that just the
professional department under trump was
a disaster too i mean barr had no
interest in doing any of this aggressive
thing now i say i say that knowing that
he did do some good things but the point
is the justice department
institutionally is a locus of evil when
it comes to public policy and they do
not believe and this was true in the
obama administration there was an ig
report they didn't believe the laws
against racial discrimination applied
the whites and voting matters
i mean that was that was the finding it
was our people who worked there told us
that we have some employ our attorneys
used to work the justice department they
were told that it's not designed we
don't believe these civil rights laws
will apply to all people we had we had
some guy in the show i'm not going to
say his name but he was arguing and very
much in favor of critical race theory
and stuff
and you know you know he's saying like
you you guys want to ban this stuff from
schools and blah blah
my response to this just simply simply
when donald trump wanted to ban the
critical race theory trainings for
contractors and stuff like that
and these leftists are like i thought
you supported free speech i'm like uh
yeah i do i do i'm just also in favor of
enforcing laws and if it's an illegal
discriminatory action based on the civil
rights law we enforce it right so you
can't come to me and be like we like the
1964 civil rights act we we like these
rulings it's like oh well trump wants to
enforce it how dare you
we should be allowed to discriminate but
you shouldn't it's like that who's that
guy was it frank herbert was his name
when i am weaker than you i asked for
freedom because it's according to your
principles when when know why i'm
stronger than you i deny your freedom
because it's according to mine was that
frank kerber said that
i'm not sure he looked at a similar
version
evil okay cool evil calls for tolerance
until it's ascendant and then it calls
for submission basically but the left is
always you know the left uses these
arguments as a tool exactly and when the
tool becomes
not useful they passed it aside so
anti-anti-discrimination they saw as a
political tool
now they don't like it they cast it
aside the supreme court they liked when
it was roe versus wade but now that
they're ruling against us oh no we gotta
cast it aside right we used to like the
senate filibuster but now we need to
eliminate the senate on top of the
defense yeah yeah that was colbert he
said that right yeah the senate the
senate so when you the the you know like
i say revolutionary moment filibuster
isn't the target the target is
eliminating any impediment
to power
amen stephen colbert goes on his show
with elizabeth warren i think this was a
week ago and he says we should get rid
of the senate and everyone laughs he's
like i'm going to say this hear me out
hear me out
why don't we abolish the senate the
whole audience laughs and he goes i'm
100 serious
yeah if you're 100 serious and your
audience is laughing at you when you say
it you're insane yeah and liz is 100
cherokee
he was like actually i'm like point zero
zero one nine percent serious but no it
goes to show you how far these people
have gone because we one thing that we
used to say to make fun of them when
they would talk about the electoral
college was that
at that point they may as well just try
to abolish representative government in
general and now they're actually doing
this and i've also seen this with
respect to the argument that's been made
about gun control i've heard a lot of
conservatives say well why not ban
automobiles because of all the people
who die in car accidents and now i'm
actually hearing left-wing people argue
that we need to shift to a national
railway oh yeah never arguments yeah
never never presume the crazy stuff yeah
yeah yeah exactly so it's like every
single it's like jokes that we will make
to highlight the ridiculousness of their
worldview tend to become positions that
they actually support within a matter of
years
authoritarianism will do that if if
their enemy makes a joke like well here
they come
authoritarians would be like they gave
us the green light let's go well well
trump was criticized for saying that um
oh look they're taking down statues of
confederates are they going to take
sound statues of jefferson and
washington i remember thinking oh yes
they will yes i mean that's perfectly i
mean we laugh at the craziness but it's
person
perfectly rational within the marxist
world view
and they don't found it funny and
they're perfectly willing to
go to these extreme circumstances i mean
look the january i call it the rump
committee the january 6 rump committee
is a one-party committee in the house
that is exercising legislative and
investigative power is it actually all
one party well there are republicans who
answer to nancy pelosi but who have not
been who don't represent the minority
party so it's a one-party operation
so how how is that consistent
with a republican form of government no
that should be an external independent
organization doing that committee well
it shouldn't be you know what they're
investigating is their political
opposition i mean that that's when you
talk about the ussr that's the playbook
also speaking of the statutes do you
remember when npr did a fact check on
trump's statement that they would
eventually go after statues of people
like washington and jefferson and they
they fact checked his prediction
before it happened saying it was
incorrect don't get me started on the
fact check they're fantastic
yeah
i used to think that we should get rid
of the republican uh republicanism i
thought the house of representatives is
this is like 2007. i was talking to mike
gravel actually he was an alaskan
senator at the time and i i was able to
communicate with him a little bit and i
thought it's just i saw them getting
bribed i saw the the stop gap of like
only these guys get to make the laws it
just felt like
they were all corrupt i wanted it gone i
was like why can't we just have
the americans pass the laws into the
senate and then let the senate be the
stop gap why do we need this house of
representatives anymore we have internet
and gravel is like no no we need the
house of representatives and i was like
is he just brainwashed because he's from
that system or do we actually need this
i don't know i don't think they should
have the monopoly on on lawmaking though
yeah i mean the founders wanted kind of
a a
the republican system is is
is has democratic
uh you know democratic outlooks but it
it it kind of is also designed to
suppress
the sign of the vote by
you know just have the popular vote be
promoted directly so
so that the passions of the moment
don't result in legislation being passed
everyone gets angry about joe rogan and
he gets banned
because there's this backlash and then
oh what happens the next day well he's
banned because it was passed because
they had a vote that was national that
resulted in getting banned you don't
want to be on the wrong end of that and
when you have
liberties that are protected by law
and are supposed to be protected by law
at all times under a constitution you
don't want to have those subjected to
uh you know the popular passions as well
so we have a republican form of
government with democratic aspects
and the left hates it we we've had this
conversation before ian where uh i said
all everyone in this room all in favor
of taking ian's stuff from him yeah
everybody yeah everybody raise your hand
everyone agrees okay ian give us your
stuff well then you'd have to send it to
the senate and the senate would look at
it and be like uh what's this insane
stuff and who's the person that tried to
pass this in the point is when you have
direct democracy we can just vote to
take from you not i'm not going to i
like the senate i'm just saying the
house of representatives i don't
understand the value
they represent the people and the senate
representatives they don't but they
don't represent the people that's the
problem they're supposed to one person
represent 700 000 people whoa whoa whoa
they represent their own interests whoa
ian
750 000 people thank you for the update
yeah it's a lot of people
so they don't and they don't and and
this is something that colbert said
when uh carson cinema was like the
filibuster
makes sure that legislation has to have
a broad range of support
colbert goes no
no
you represent 40 he's like the party
filibustering represents 41 million less
people
colbert thinks
that the 50
or the 49 percent of illinois that are
republican or whatever the number is
just blindly agree
with their senator because the election
was won yeah no that's not how it works
right in fact there's a great deal of
republicans and many of these blue
states who are very very very unhappy so
when colbert is like but you but you
represent more people yeah well those 41
million people are probably
conservatives who don't like you who
don't agree with you so it's not as
simple as just be like do whatever you
want when you get power well i mean it's
it's like this argument about the
popular versus the electoral vote what
the left does is they take numbers
and apply them to a game
that the numbers aren't
that are outside the game's rules
so oh no the yankees really won last
year because they got more strikeouts
than whoever won the world series well
that may be interesting as a matter of
fact
but that's not the way the game was
played and no one played the game to get
more strikes exactly so no one plays the
game in presidential elections to get
more of the popular vote so it's
irrelevant to analysis of who gets more
votes or not yeah and it's the same at
the congressional level in the senate
level it's the popular vote it's not
it's not relevant
to the game like it's an indication
because if one team got like
a hundred times more strikeouts than any
other team but they still didn't win you
might think maybe the game's being
played wrong well for instance trump
doesn't have to trump doesn't campaign
in california
so all that popular vote that's run up
for democrats in california
is never countered because playing the
game doesn't mean repub doesn't means
that republicans don't go and ask for
the popular vote now if there was a
popular vote contest every four years
democrats think they'd win
no the game would change and republicans
would start agitating for the popular
vote and who knows who would win yeah
well well no if they're if there was a
popular if if one day they said hey
everybody guess what 2024 is gonna be
popular vote
it wouldn't just change the rules of the
game the country would be ripped apart
by chaos and fighting of course the left
doesn't believe in the popular vote
because they want to change electoral
college so let's say that texas
votes majority for trump but the
majority of electors are voting for uh
for biden or the popular vote is
different in other states texas has to
ignore their popular vote right yeah
it's it's all a game well and i prefer
the game the founders set out for us
rather than the game the left is trying
to come up with now yeah so the first
time i ever voted was in cook county um
but
how many times did you vote yeah exactly
only once believe it or not but uh i
don't question the legitimacy of cook
county elections i will say this i
remember feeling like it was a protest
vote because it's just such a deep blue
county and illinois such a blue state
that i didn't think it was going to have
any effect so i voted for who i wanted
to but i recognized probably wasn't
going to have an effect and i knew a lot
of people who didn't vote a lot of
conservatives who didn't vote because
they knew the state was going to go blue
i think you're right that if we did
change to a system that was purely based
on the popular vote there actually is a
chance that the republicans would win
because a lot of people who are
disillusioned by the politics of their
local
municipality or state would start voting
that said i agree with you it's not and
it would not be an improvement
i want to talk to you guys about uh the
leftists in this country and we'll segue
into that we got the story from mashable
oh man anti-work subreddit goes private
after rough fox news interview yikes
saith mashable
i would like to introduce you to a
subreddit called anti-work
my understanding after uh some cursory
research is that the point of this forum
was it was people who thought no one
should have to have a job you should be
allowed to get food shelter and whatever
given to you without doing any work
it started to grow rapidly 1.7 million
followers of this subreddit's form
it quickly changed however into a work
reform where it was like hey we just
want rights we want to do work but we
got to get paid better
sure now ultimately i think this message
is co-opted by the left and that's what
poisoned it but here's what happens
fox news reaches out to interview one of
them someone from the the forum of 1.7
million people who don't want to work or
who don't like working
and
my so this is what i read basically
someone they all held a poll where they
said okay should we do this everyone
voted the majority said do not go on fox
news oh boy one of the moderators
decided to go on fox news anyway it was
a
um
autistic non-binary individual i believe
who appeared on fox news wouldn't look
directly into the camera and was shying
away in a messy room with an
inarticulate message that seemed
wishy-washy saying things like i have to
walk dogs 25 hours a week and i
shouldn't have to do that to be able to
eat and survive
and i think probably that was more
articulate than the person was
this caused brigading people rushing
into the subreddit and then ultimately
it shut down now they're saying they may
come back but what i find fascinating
this whole story
the anti-work movement
the rapid explosive spread fox news
covered this from you know only a year
ago to you know tens of thousands of
followers to 1.7 million
when you go to the subreddit these are
people who are outright saying you know
i shouldn't have to have a job
this is the mentality of the modern left
so i'll warn i will first say
a lot of the work reform arguments from
many of these people many of them
leftists i completely agree with someone
takes out 20 grand in school loans now
they owe 100 because of interest and i'm
like okay that i can understand is a
problem
if you take out a loan for 20 grand and
there's some interest on it i can
recognize you know you got to pay it
back and you got to pay back the
interest but when it's when it's massive
and that's for a lot of people then i'm
basically like yo the system is corrupt
we got to shut that down i can respect
that but when you come out and say
things like and
i shouldn't have to do any work i should
just get stuff
i'm like which slave
you know will you be
which person will you be enslaving which
group of people in order to have them do
the work to make your food because food
doesn't come from nowhere
i mean even when it grows on the trees
someone's still gotta go get it for you
exactly no such thing as free lunch and
every single thing you have that you
didn't work for somebody worked for
without having and sometimes that's fine
because it's voluntary somebody gave the
charity they wanted to help you and then
sometimes that's not fine because it was
forcibly taken from the person when you
yourself could have been earning money
it's interesting how our conception of
work has changed
over the past hundred years maybe even
just the past 50 years but people used
to see their job as something that gave
them meaning and they no longer do and
there are a lot of reasons for that and
i'm not just blaming workers themselves
for having this attitude i think in many
respects the working class are not
treated well i don't think the left has
done a great job representing them
historically and i think that they need
people who are willing to fight for them
who actually have some level of contact
with them and don't despise them and
their values which they don't right now
but
ultimately people used to conceive of
their work as that which they
contributed
and that which they were adding and now
we have this idea that there are certain
jobs that are worth doing because what
is being done at those jobs is valuable
and then basically every other job is
pointless and it's humiliating to have
to do it but the reality is there's
dignity in all work and yes workers
should be treated with more dignity i
agree with that completely but the idea
that well there are just certain jobs
nobody should have to do is absurd
because all of those jobs need doing so
what you should be saying is respect the
people doing it you shouldn't be saying
i shouldn't have to work to survive it's
insane there's a meme that i saw that i
think sums up a lot of the culture war
it was my brother posted it it said
people who are unvaccinated and oppose
the vaccines
don't want you to get it because they're
scared you could die
and the people who are vaccinated and
want you to get it are scared they could
die
and regardless of the vaccine opinion
i'm not asserting anything about
vaccines it's just it's just a meme yeah
it's just interesting that there's this
perspective of oh no
i don't want you to be hurt and the
other perspective is you better do this
so i don't get hurt yeah i bring that up
because and always talk to your doctor
about private medical decisions but i
bring this up in this context because
what i see often from the left and like
the anti-work community is i shouldn't
have to work and i should get stuff
and then my attitude is let me make as
much stuff as possible and then help
others with that stuff exactly well it's
so weird isn't it yeah and so i think
historically and again it's like this is
easy for me to say right because i
started a small business when i was 18
years old it turned out to be very
successful i get to do something that's
difficult at times but that i genuinely
love doing and there are a lot of people
who have jobs that are very difficult
they're not in the position that i'm in
and so i i totally understand that but
at the same time i'll hear people say
things like you know i have to work for
40 hours a week that's unnatural in the
past people used to take pride in the
fact that they were spending that amount
of time contributing right the problem
now is in this job economy that we've
found ourselves in the federal reserve
loves this they want two people and
they're like i don't have a job what do
i do
the federal reserve will be like well we
have an idea or whoever is in in control
you dig a hole and then you come over
and fill that hole back up once it's
done and we'll print a hundred thousand
dollars and then we'll give you 50 000
and you 50 000 but you're gonna have to
start paying us interest back on that
100 grand so they win they the more
money they can give out the winner the
more win they get so people are are
aware they've awakened to the
pointlessness of a lot of these jobs now
when you define work that's a scientific
word that means it's an energy transfer
in jewels it can be measured
we're working right now if you're
thinking you're producing work what is
the work is it contributing to society
yeah so important and that's really
important because you sort of mentioned
these work projects and i've heard
people discuss this idea that yeah in
times of economic downturn what we
should be doing is creating these jobs
that we don't actually need so that we
can get people back in the workforce
and what that fails to take into account
is that the purpose of a job isn't
simply so that somebody can have
something to do all day the purpose of a
job is to find a way for a person to be
able to contribute to society at large
and it goes back to what we were
discussing earlier with these
discriminatory practices of only wanting
to hire someone on the basis of their
sex or skin color because what you're
basically saying at that point is we're
not interested in whether you're
qualified for the position because the
position doesn't exist for the people
you're supposed to serve in that role
the position exists for you to feel
special because you have that position
that is how we view work nowadays i'm
just going to leapfrog so much of this
conversation because i'm in my mind i'm
just like you know hopscotching through
all the points at church that that's
where where it ends up church it's
exactly community people have no purpose
yeah they have no purpose so when
they're complaining about work it's
because these jobs aren't fulfilling to
them yeah i feel like they're wasting
their times their lives and their energy
and they want to do something else but
they don't have anything else either so
they get ideological yeah i'm not saying
uh so i just want to clarify too i'm not
an overtly religious person
but my point is that
when there was church there was
community and there was purpose for
people and that's what people are
lacking now now that we're an
increasingly secular country exactly and
i'll add this and also clarify in case
there's any doubt about this here um as
i've mentioned earlier i think the
working class does need to be treated
better i think there are so many jobs
that we view as indignant or beneath
people and they're not and part of the
way we change that is we really need to
admire the people who do those jobs
because they're really important and
church is important here because as a
roman catholic at basically every church
that i've been to in my adult life and
particularly the the latin mass that
i've attended for the past few years
there is an intersection of so many
different people from various economic
classes and standings
and i don't think people have that
anymore because they don't have religion
when i think about the friends that i've
made through through my church and my
primary friend group basically all from
different income brackets i can't think
of any other social organization i'm a
part of where that's the case public
school and but i think no but i think
but part of why i think that's really
helpful is because it does put you in
touch with like i'm i'm not only if i
wasn't going to that church if that
wasn't my faith community there i might
only be in touch with other people
working in artistic fields or doing
politics on the internet but instead i'm
in touch with people who are plumbers or
um
you know painters artists of a different
variety or work for a union we we should
create an award ceremony for trade jobs
so that we can highlight i'm half
kidding but you know we as a society we
we uh sports uh athletes celebrities
they get all of the attention we have to
give and then the people who are
actually making this country work don't
get any of it and it's i think there's a
spiritual component you're right to say
that but i also think there's this
elitism
as well that work is beneath me yes that
i shouldn't have to do this
and one of the arguments that's always
bothered me about immigration and legal
immigration is like they do the jobs
that americans
do
i'm like well first of all there's
virtually no industry where immigrants
are the majority
and so americans are doing these jobs
and they're not beneath anybody to do in
fact many of our parents and
grandparents did jobs like this as well
and it wasn't beneath them yeah and they
they recognized that the work and the
money they ra they earned from that
help help
you know help provide for their families
which was the most important thing in
the world so they're elitists they're
torn from the world from the community
as you talk about spiritually
and there's this leftist contempt
generally for the for the concept of
work you go to the anti-works subreddit
what do you see they're related
subreddits are socialist communist
anarchists leftist anarchists you look
at the related subjects work reform the
communist fist is their symbol
it's remarkable this this ideology that
that that infects these these these
forums when the issue is more to do with
uh you know what you can contribute the
just doing hard work rolling up your
sleeves it's not about anybody else it's
not about a grand ideology it's not
about someone ripping you off it's about
you valuing your valuing your life your
time your energy and what you do but all
of them just get infected by leftist
ideology then in comes the cultural
leftist ideology and then they imploded
themselves yeah well and you know this
idea that there are jobs that americans
are unwilling to do i mean this is a
country where we have abortionists
pornographers prostitutes the idea that
there are just these jobs that are so
far beneath the dignity of americans and
what they're willing to accept is
ridiculous it is the case that there are
certain wages an american will not work
for and that is why they want to import
people to do those jobs here's the big
problem with the leftist ideology in
these subreddits is that they're doing
nothing to stop the mass wave of illegal
immigration that's right and so they're
wondering why it is you you bring up
there's wages they won't work for well
when you bring in to where we have two
million people entering this country un
without any any uh sense of where they
would go and how they will survive all
of a sudden now these college kids who
are looking for entry level positions
they're not you're not you're not going
to get out of college and go work for a
firm you can get out of college and go
work for a starbucks something while you
try to figure things out maybe find an
internship but you're not going to do
that either because now all of a sudden
you're walking up and you're seeing a
huge line of people who want work
so all of these entry-level positions
that you know they say the minimum wage
should be 15 an hour it would be if the
supply of low-skilled labor was reduced
well you know the unions used to be
opposed to mass immigration if they were
honest you if they were well-run union
unions who were creative they'd be
saying
okay well if we're going to have a
government program that depresses wages
meaning mass immigration well we have to
make up for that with the with as you
point out with an increase in the
minimum wage so big corporations you can
get your immigrants but we get on our
side because we're subsidizing your
labor costs with the government program
we get to
ensure that our employees and and and
union members get increased wages uh
if it's what's a major what if you raise
the minimum wage only for large
corporations
they don't care
that they wouldn't surrounding errors
but what would happen is they couldn't
hire
but more people would be benefiting from
working there but they would still limit
their ability to higher mass they would
just increase the prices and it would
have the same effect on the on the local
economy but then people would buy their
stuff because their prices would go up
that's it they worked that's that's
that's not even that's that's maybe
partial they'd hire less people to save
the money but what they would do is the
business couldn't grow no no ian
here's what would happen
if you went to starbucks and said and
they and they do increase minimum wage
based on company size as well in a lot
of places like if you have 50 or more
employees or 150 but here's what happens
starbucks
uh well you know let's not say starbucks
let's say
s bucks
uh uh just a word i made up seattle
bucks cafe will find a location where
there's a mom and pop cafe they'll open
up next door and purposefully lose money
with ridiculously low prices you know
why because a regular person is going to
walk up and they'll see mom and pop shop
five buck frappuccino and they're gonna
look over at starbucks for buck
frappuccino starbucks loses a dollar on
every sale but they're strangling yes
the small business who doesn't have the
coffers to fight back so if you came out
and said okay okay then we should raise
the minimum wage on these big you know
these bigger companies walmart's going
to sit back with the cigar in their
mouth and be like
oh we can sink all of them
we're going to drop our prices because
we have billions upon billions in
profits we're going to take a 20 loss on
that store and we'll pay your minimum
wage and then once we eliminate all of
the local all all the local shops local
bakery is gone local butcher shop is
gone local clothing store is gone then
we're going to crank the prices way up
to accommodate those sausages and you
can't do anything about it
inflated wages and reduce the the cost
of their sales i think that's a big risk
for a large corp that's a big risk no it
isn't i think it is
cisco starbucks is across the street
from starbucks i'm not even kidding have
you guys seen this yeah all over the
place there's literally a starbucks and
a cross street there's a starbucks
inside of a star no that was an onion
article no that was an onion article it
sounds tricky it might happen in chicago
there was one intersection where there's
on on the southwest corner starbucks in
the northeast corner of starbucks
they
they don't make money doing that they
dominate and take over bro these
corporations make so much in profits
with with all of these locations that
they can sacrifice one location to
defeat you the people the working class
oh so you think they'll lower the prices
at a specific location that's what they
do so if you know a local jurisdiction
says we're you know this our city is
increasing the minimum wage they'll say
okay we will pay that and then we're not
going to raise prices we're going to
make sure our prices are low enough that
anyone who could compete with us in an
you know x mile radius is is put out of
business
then we can charge whatever we want and
they'll get their money back if if you
had to to an ignorant populace yeah that
would work
people know there's all the time yeah
all the time they do it all the time to
a [ __ ] in a pop an ignorant populist
if people knew what they were doing and
that they were trying to put businesses
out of business and they realized that
they would take place this is why i said
yes i do
you do but let i said this yesterday let
me know if you agree tom i said if you
went to your average american i don't
care if they're liberal conservative
otherwise and said
all of the good in your life your wages
the cheap gas everything we will allow
you to keep but we need you to sign this
document to kill a bunch of kids
overseas
i i say they would sign it i say the
average american would be like don't end
on just don't tell my friends i did
people walk up to this to starbucks
knowing exactly you know who they are
and what they do right i mean we just
went and bought a bunch of starbucks
because they got rid of the vaccine
mandate that's just me in on this one
you did it tim yeah but yeah i stand by
i stand by when a company does the right
thing i want them to do more of the
right thing so i'll call them out now
and it's not just about starbucks
because i you know look
i've only heard the anecdotes about
starbucks
go ahead now i was going to say like
fact check me on that i may be wrong
but yeah i don't know about it you know
why specifically but it is true that
businesses will intentionally take a
loss in order to destroy them can they
take the level of loss of having their
their wages go up and their costs their
sales
depends on how much the changes in
either direction the quote nancy pelosi
when she's defending her individualized
stock trades that's capitalism
yeah and the challenge is that you may
not like it it's like how do you fix it
and the only way to fix it is through a
regulatory scheme
run by incompetence liars or lying
incompetence
so there's there's no good answer to
that if you don't you know i i sometimes
shop in places that aren't chained
stores because i know i'm getting a
little bit more customer service and
that's good and other times i'll go to
starbucks because i like the coffee
there yeah i got to be honest out here
even in west virginia the local uh
coffee and bagel shop has a mask mandate
by choice and the starbucks doesn't
drop that mandate dog you heard of here
first can we talk about nancy pelosi for
a second
so she's running for re-election nancy
pelosi has announced he's running for
re-election oh good for him
is she just doing this because it looks
like the demo the 2029 democrats are
resigning 2020 you mean you mean the 29
democrats are resigning yeah 29
democrats are about to resign so that
she's like well we're going to lose the
entire house to the republicans so i
need to stay here is that you think
that's why she's yeah i mean she can
retire at any time or end her campaign
at any time so you know you know what i
think we should do and uh uh and hear me
out okay 100 serious hearing i believe
some nice gentleman should bring in a
wheelchair to her office place her in it
put a blanket on her lap and wheel her
out bring her to a home
and make sure she's comfortable
and then we the people will decide what
to do next
are you suggesting she has a joe biden
problem
nancy pelosi yeah i mean she's she's
just old and out of touch and
incompetent and at a certain point we
have we have an age minimum but perhaps
we require an age limit as well she
shakes when she talks well we were
talking about fallout i mean we're
talking about this uh before before the
show started you know compare and
contrast the mental acuity
of dr
who's 81 exactly joe biden and or nancy
pelosi or many others
to be fair fauci is flip-flopped so
often maybe he does have
some kind of brain thing but i mean it's
true it's so much more about the
individual person it's very you can't
really put in a blanket statement say at
this age the person has to step down
because some people are just sharp at an
older the nice thing about comparing
biden then why do we have an age minimum
minimum no i mean i well i think the age
minimum is a life experience thing i
think that's a big part of it i mean do
you want like a 21 year old in any of
these positions yo if there's somebody
who started working in you know like a
factory with like their family or
whatever when they were seven
and they've got 15 years of experience
in
you know a political and industrial
environment
it's better than a 25 year old who just
graduated from college what about
non-americans i hear what you're saying
what do you mean like elon
a non-american that moves to the united
states when they're two but they can't
be president and they have all these
restrictions on what they can be in
government do you think that we should
get rid of that stuff no i think that's
good it's fine but age restrictions you
think we should get rid of age
restrictions no i'm i'm in favor of
putting more on oh i think you said a
young genius
should have i said we should have an age
limit for old people and he said but no
you can't determine the life experience
you know yeah blah some people and then
i said well for we do it for young
people my point is we have a we have a
minimum we should have a maximum i'm not
saying definitively i completely 100
believe we should have a maximum i'm
saying let's entertain the possibility
that someone who's 80 should probably
retire you could do cognitive tests but
this is so the laws if they are passing
they will not live underneath you okay
so
you know if a society grows great when
when people plant trees whose shade they
know they'll never sit beneath 80 year
olds like pelosi and old people like
biden are not planting trees for anyone
yeah they're
they're not going to see whatever
happens they don't care it's a
complicated go ahead sorry well it's
just it's a complicated thing because
i do think that it's it's an age floor
is a a bit different from an aged
ceiling here
but
ultimately we have a system that's
structured so that like
because you leave office eventually
everyone's sort of incentivized to just
pull what they can out of the system for
as long as they can until they leave
without really thinking about the
long-term consequences because let's say
you have a young
politician and
sure it's like they're not going to have
to live under the policies anyway
because there are different laws for
them they're above it
well so my proposal was the island
the the island which is as soon as you
leave office you get sent to an island
where you will live with other people
who have left office you will you will
not you will own nothing and you'll be
happy
i have an island where i put people but
would do different categories
a flying island i don't know maybe they
can go along with them uh
i don't seriously think you know that
idea uh is the right idea but i i'm just
trying to think like how do you stop
someone from saying i'm gonna run for
office i'm gonna get in i'm gonna
extract as much as i can and then i'm
gonna run away you don't that's all any
of them do well i mean how do you stop
it
i don't know it might be built into
democracy and representative
i i
this is advice as head of judicial watch
we're nonpartisan i give to all
politicians
to me running on a reform agenda
would be a solution there and that
agenda would include term limits
balanced budget amendments significant
cuts to the federal government
because what happens is it's not someone
who's 80 it's someone who's 80 who got
there when they were 40.
you know i prefer having someone there
75 to 85 there for 10 years you know
that experience is of great value to
society so that's not the issue the
issue is the term of office that
politicians are in and to me you know i
know there are a lot of conservatives
who don't like the idea of term limits i
don't think it's a silver bullet but
what happens is it breeds the worst
aspects of being a politician you're
right citizens
cynicism
institutionalism contempt for other
people's views aren't in congress
because you've known it all since you've
been there forever no no no we need new
blood every every few years you're right
and
i think i i will revise my the island
statement and just say perhaps solution
is logan's run
great movie yeah sheamus are you
familiar i have i have not seen logan's
right so when you turn watching when you
turn 30 you uh you know you get you
shuffle off the mortal coil are you so
people have life boiling it people have
lights yeah it's i mean
we laugh well that's been the approach
with bro
briar could die in office
you know that's why they were angry at
uh what's ruth bader ginsburg that's how
she died during the trump administration
she should have gotten out that's a
great uh uh
uh satirical article red light on
briar's hand begins blinking red yeah
that's forced to retire that's the way
the left looks at supreme court justices
in logan's run they had lights on their
hands and it was like when they were
young it was green when they're getting
old turns yellow and they when they're
about to turn 30 it starts blinking red
and then logan's run is you know he runs
yeah he's like i don't want to die
they kind of did so there was a film i
saw a few years ago it was like i saw it
recently but it came out about 10 years
ago it's with justin timberlake it's not
exactly the same but you have like you
have a bar code on your arm that says
the amount of time that you're alive for
when it counts down to zero and you can
buy time but you can buy time yeah so
wealth is the amount of time you have so
it's like not exactly the same but kind
of a different twist on it yeah that
one's so i think i saw that i think
that's a cool concept yeah so maybe
maybe uh we
i don't know it's weird these these
sci-fi dystopian movies aren't really
the same
it would have to be in a dream like they
trap you in your metaverse and then you
have to run in the dream because then
because in the real life if you try and
run there's drone bombs and like blazes
but in the dream you can run away no no
ian you run for office
and you can run to get away from you
like
so a term is four years you run for
congress boom you're in for four years
as soon as that four uses up there's no
re-election you get locked in the matrix
wow that's it you're just out we don't
have the technology so it's just gonna
be mark zuckerberg like duct taping
oculus to your forehead and putting in
the metaverse like you can't get out
you're covered up that source yeah
the theory is there was an old the old
play dr marlowe
by uh well no faustus by christopher
marlowe uh he's dr faustus yeah faustus
is dealing with the devil mephistopheles
and he said how did you get out of hell
mephistopheles he said this is hell nor
am i out of it so
we're still in the matrix yeah man
you know maybe maybe i think the
metaverse is coming i think we're all
gonna get locked inside of it we're in a
matrix you can measure the matrix we're
in if you know how much of something
what it is and where it is and you can
measure that in the xyz axis this cube
that we're within okay i have no idea
what that means
define them
my proposal is uh is this
when we elect joe rogan as president in
2028 he should issue an executive order
mandating dmt passport requirements for
access to bars restaurants and
universities ideally did you smoke your
dmt right have you smoked that's why
you had your dmt booster
it wears off
i think that joe rogan's credit i don't
think joe rogan would vote for joe rogan
no i agree good point i love the
humility that's true but the great thing
about joe is it's his guests they talk a
lot about joe rogan and he is a genius
like he'll talk himself down but the way
he can sit there and listen to jordan
peterson you need a genius he's the
larry king of the internet age yeah and
shout out to his guests i mean there is
there is something to be said about a
passport for some kind of deeper
understanding of reality i don't think
it's necessarily you know dmt that's the
joke
but
perhaps if we society where like
you know
a service guarantees citizenship or
something that affect you know like
you need to understand something you
need to do work and contribute for
something in order to to get something
in return right now it's it's you know
we had that famous quote
ask not what your country can do for you
but what you can do for your country
it's completely inverted these days yeah
yeah well there's there's a war on
citizenship i mean the whole the whole
zeitgeist now is to eliminate the
distinctions between citizens and
non-citizens oh new york's yeah so so
i mean they want you to be it's
offensive to the transnational
progressives they don't believe in
nation states and sovereignty because it
gets in the way
of the communist utopia they're pushing
yeah you know and i wouldn't have said
this six years i mean you know you knew
this this was out there among the
marxists for a long time but now there's
kind of a rising communism in a major
party here in the country
that that this is this is this is their
go-to strategy it's not coincidence i
mean when crt is the guiding movement
narrative for a presidential
administration
you know those those pushing it must be
very proud dude build back better is a
klaus schwab thing now correct me if i'm
wrong but this is part of the world
economic forum's great reset is build
back better this is where i first heard
of it and then all of a sudden a year
later joe biden is saying those words as
if we're gonna do it without referencing
klaus schwab and please correct me if
i'm wrong if klaus schwab didn't say it
then i'm totally off base but i remember
talking it was all over europe i think
boris johnson claimed uh biden stole it
from him
because buildback batter was all over
europe okay well nancy pelosi uh used
drain the swamp when she ran for off ran
for the republic ran to take control of
congress in 2010. wow there's nothing
new under the sun yep and make america
great again was uh ronald reagan yeah
warning in america yeah
in america this is exactly right klaus
schwab is first started circulating the
idea of the great reset which uses build
back better integral parts so so we are
we're no longer are we allowed to say
the right reset yeah great reset is very
very plain i know all these algorithms
get triggered by certain words it's
either
directly influenced and has co-opted our
president or indirectly but this
methodology of building back better with
a socialized corporate
political government state is in joe
biden's head whether he realizes it or
not well certainly wikovit you know
initially there was this panicked crazed
decision making on the shutdowns now
it's vindictive and vicious
and they see it as an opportunity for
dramatic political and social change i
mean i i don't think it's any mistake
you had this reddit thing pop up with i
don't want to work yeah after two years
of people not having to work yeah all
right everybody let's go to super chats
if you have not already smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends it really
does help and uh go to timcast.com
subscribe we have a members only segment
talking about election stuff that'll be
up around 11 or so p.m but let's read we
got here we got dylan hernandez says i
subscribed to your tim cast monthly plan
i used paypal to leave it as my auto pay
have not used paypal in months just let
the payments go through but days ago
paypal banned my account didn't do
anything but give you money
yup i can't say i'm surprised um i don't
know if anything if it has anything to
do with us but um maybe i don't know
maybe it was because you didn't use the
account to be completely honest if you
set up an account with paypal and then
you said turn on autopay and then don't
do anything with it they might send you
an email and be like hey is this account
still active and if you're not really
paying attention they might say okay
shut it down that could be one reason i
don't know i know all right let's see
blue c says check my ads posted you are
next yeah that's
they're just you know trying really
really hard to get attention so
congratulations the super chat works in
their favor but um i'll be honest we we
are principally not funded by ads you
know we uh it's this weirdest thing
where the left is going after like dan
bongino
and uh i think ben shapiro maybe i don't
know but it has something to do with
january 6
and they're like we're gonna get all
their advertisers removed from their
show and i'm just like we do direct ad
reads like i read the ads in the show
and we only do six per month
so like so you do advertising like
traditional radio advertising where the
host is reading an ad you know yeah yeah
it's all it's all like it's clean like
directly with us from people who know us
and ask us like the companies come to us
and they're like hey we want to be on
your show so i don't i don't i don't i
don't get it
look it's just grifting it's just people
we have to pay you to encourage people
to donate to judicial watch you have to
pay me to do it would we have to oh i
mean or you can just come on the show
and shout out to you so much but uh for
the most part but that's the way you
would do it you know you know someone
and they know you and you
you know for like for judicial watch
stuff so sleeping giants isn't going to
be able to stop anyone from advertising
well that's basically what it is yeah
it's it's a it's a lady who got really
mad because she tried claiming she
started it when she didn't and then like
so she's trying to be like it was me but
it wasn't some other guy or something
like that so now she's trying to
get attention by you know posting
overtly fake garbage uh as everybody
watches the show knows she's made the
claim that i've pushed the big lie that
donald trump won the election which i've
never once stated not one not one time
and for this the trump supporters are
very mad at me they don't like me for it
but uh we're we're funded by members at
timcast.com
so what makes this show work timcast.com
memberships what makes our journalists
able to do their jobs your membership at
timcast.com so when these people just
make up these lies like we're going to
go after their advertisers and our
advertisements are like
0.1 i think it's like 0.01 of the
revenue it's so ridiculously small it's
completely negligible and i'm just like
i actually was talking to the company
and i was like do we even need this like
do we do we need to do this it's like
well is it worth it you should because
the idea is that you know once the
website gets bigger and has much more
traffic it could become substantial so
you know for the most part
they're just grifters who are trying to
use the fact that our show is growing to
and and hatred from trolls or whatever
to make money and they've made tens of
thousands of dollars offline they
overtly lie they make things up they
completely fabricate things and i will
state for the record right now as a
statement of fact that these individuals
fabricate information to to trick people
into giving them money and i believe it
is an act of fraud
yeah i can i can i can i can assert that
with uh uh
i mean look i'll be honest the lies are
so obvious
that like it's it's not even a question
for me to say that's my view generally
about big tech it's all fraud the
censorship is evidence of fraud oh wow
men should be prosecuted but why do you
say fraud because they're saying they're
censoring you for reason a when in fact
it's reason b so they're lying to users
shareholders regulators and congress
interesting
securities exchange commission federal
trade commission
congress doj and i trust whatever should
be investigating the fraud yeah all
right michael holder says regarding the
race swapping characters thing it's not
actually about the race swapping it's
that everyone in hollywood has become
race obsessed ideologues and turn
everything they write into woke veggie
tales ask eric july about it next time
he's on he'll talk your ears off about
it oh no no i i i i get it for sure you
know we were talking last night about uh
titans it's the dc show yeah one of the
characters starfire is in the comics
she's like an orange alien and they cast
a black woman to play starfire there was
like this big uproar i guess a lot of
people were angry like why are they you
know starfire is not black or whatever
and my attitude was like it's an alien
okay people anyone could play this
character i don't understand why anyone
will be mad about that but their their
response is it's not really about that
it's about the race obsession and the
and the wokeness and the crt and stuff
and like that i get yeah
i call it racialism yes this obsession
and uh
it's disturbing it's really disturbing i
agree man i agree all right joker says
shim cast forever beautiful thank you so
much and honestly it has been forever
since i've been on it's so great to be
back we gotta get we have this tim cast
thing that's that's uh behind our guests
all the time you can see it uh
someone made it for us we need to get
one that says shim cast we got anyone
you guys someone wants to send us a shim
cast
they were looking for something to put
up behind me so
tim just pins a lint roller to the wall
right there this is what i'm working
with he was actually rolling the lint
off him before he did it
that sheamus is dirty
well i don't think there needs to be any
indication is that the anti-irish
subtext too exactly all right there's
nothing to do with him being irish
youtube will ban you i don't like this
racialism
netflix is going to reboot me
all right rvdl says neil hoped to burn
out but he chose to fade away what a sad
old man
i just listened to uh sweet judy blue
eyes
neil young sad neil yeah what is this uh
seleuc erotic says i hope neil young
will remember a southern man don't need
him around anyhow sweet home alabama
yeah they don't need him around neither
do we you could be an internet person
you could be a freedom loving person you
could be a music or podcast listener
none of us need you neil young sorry
spotify don't need them around that's it
yeah they don't
dj buddy's rock garden says dude i'm 61
and a loyal listener f neil young
disaffected liberal
isn't it sad you know you know he's an
okay boomer he's an okay boomer love him
it was uh uh
the thing about
the the thing about neil young is that
he's this guy was supposed to be
protesting you know rocking in the free
world
and he's just an establishment chill the
problem he was just marketing the whole
time when you're famous for something
there's a tendency to think that you're
supposed to keep doing that thing you
got famous for to continue to be famous
so he got really well known for being
you know for protesting and it's like at
some point you you can change course you
don't need to keep being the guy that
poured ketchup on your head
every video to try and one-up what made
you get there you know now you're there
you can i i had i was in the shower man
i almost came out hot on neil young just
ripping him to shreds personally but i
don't really know exactly what his his
thought process is here so i'm not gonna
go too hard on him
let me uh
earmuffs for your kids
lee says i'm one of the few cnn viewers
i was channel surfing and my bf came
over we started participating in adult
activities and he threw the remote
stopping it on cnn i'm sorry my worst
mistake and biggest regret
could you imagine with like don lemon in
the background
how would that even work for any any
human would work mind over matter mind
over matter
desperately trying to focus on something
else
jim acosta comes on yeah i'm sorry man
nope
all right waffle sensei says sheamus
would you consider filling in for luke
till he gets back you're hilarious and
we love you dude oh i love you thank you
so much for saying that so yeah tim and
i have definitely been talking about it
i might be hanging out for a little
while and just yeah sheamus came to me
and asked i was begging i said to him
please i started laughing you begged me
he said sheamus we need you we need you
over here shim cast is gonna fall apart
without the original shim sham himself
and i said i'll get here i'll come there
as fast as i can because i'm a good
friend and i got in my car to me and i
drove you hours and hours he was like i
couldn't help but notice luke is gone
and i was like and and he was like you
think there's any chance i don't know
like maybe i could and i was like
sheamus you think i would put you in
luke's chair i called luke luke
immediately started screaming with
laughter that that is not even remotely
what happens because that is not even
what happened anyone who watches the
vlogs
a few months he left so now that's
that's where he would sit anyone who
watches the vlog will know the following
is true all right
luke was on his way out old model past
his expiration date
gotta bring in gotta bring in the
dancing pelosi of tim exactly
we will be back we're putting age limits
i think we're putting away
he's going to take offense to that
and luke
comes to me despite the fact that i've
been nothing but respectful and admiring
towards the polish people and he starts
trashing
my ethnic background and i said look tim
i'm going to be honest i think this
guy's a pr disaster i think he's going
to get you in trouble
tim said you're right sheamus i've been
thinking about it i want to ask you on
he kicked luke out that day pack your
bags funny in all seriousness just
expose our whole pr campaign you want to
support luke rutkowski go to the best
political shirts.com
and then send your favorite shirt
changed his mascot to like non-binary so
that we wouldn't uh have any controversy
what actually happened is that uh luke
left and i said you know we can we can
see if we can have some people come in
and out we have different cast you know
people who work work at the castle i
work for timcast.com and then sheamus
was like i'm going to be heading back
and i said uh when are you coming back
and he said i think i might be back in a
day or so and i was like can you try and
get back before the show because we
could really use you on the show and
sheamus was like yeah for sure and then
that's what that's what really happened
well you told me first of all that is
not what happened i did not say i was
gonna be back in a day or so it's sim
said if you're not back in a day or so
this is going to fall apart but i
actually said it like if you're not back
in a day or so
and my arms are going like this if
you're not back by the end of the day
speaking of which check out the newest
freedom tunes everybody pretty good
tucker carlson and bernie sanders but
yeah that's what happened but yes so i
will be filling in for a little while
yes uh sheamus will be we'll be filling
in i mean uh you know before luke showed
up we didn't actually have a fourth
person you know and then when we built
this new studio studio we had a fourth
person in mind because it used to just
be three that's tim putting me on notice
he's like i'm just letting you know we
didn't always have four now yeah you can
have a fifth yeah we do yeah sometimes
but too many people becomes a cacophony
right
you know what happens yeah all right we
got one we got this one from wonder
without the fear says trucker's convoy
2022 this needs to be addressed this
this peaceful and truckers helps
everyone many usa truckers are coming up
to ca so much love keep it peaceful yeah
did you guys hear uh uh this massive
trucker convoy man yeah and the gofundme
something about this gofundme they had a
five million and they froze this five
million bucks going to the truckers of
course what's up with that well go fund
me is like until you can give us a plan
as to what you're to do with the money
frozen right you know i uh
i had judicial watch do a petition to
get a special counsel for uh joe biden
and i was a little nervous about using
change.org but i did it and 350 000
people have signed up and the people
saying well that's a left with leftist
organization it's like well good
yeah what better place than to
advocate uh holding joe biden
accountable than on change.org
so what are these these truckers doing
exactly they're protesting the vax
mandates and what are they doing are
they like on the road just driving yeah
yeah yeah it's just a big good imagine
imaginative supply chain imagine
screwing with truckers right now how
stupid house unbelievable
you have to be it's because
everyone has to obey does it matter if
it's going to make life way more
difficult for everybody they're out of
line and they have to be punished to be
fair though imagine screwing with
truckers at any point no that's also
true but especially now you're
absolutely right we really depend on
them but now of all times like when
there's already supply chain issues when
we're already having food shortages i
know who we're gonna screw with the
people who bring us our food brilliant
great job thank you brandon all right we
got recusa says tim waiting for you to
pull your bret mason signature telly off
the wall and break out and we're not
gonna take it i can dream can't i
well we were uh we were planning on
doing a show when we were gonna have um
uh we're gonna have michael graves
but he couldn't he didn't he uh he
couldn't make it we used to do friday
night jam sessions but we were set up
for it for the most part so maybe you
know maybe especially when we have
guests on that are musicians which
probably will be correct that would be
great yeah we used to do friday night we
would just jam out for like a half an
hour after the show play songs play
music people clipped a whole bunch of my
songs and put them up which they were
like
after talking for like seven hours in
one day then trying to sing was just
brutal no i believe it yeah
they're good though those video clips
are great a lot of yeah that's how i
learned a lot of your music is through
those clips there you go i'm surprised
they got a lot of views on some of them
all right nick rose says sheamus is
boondock saints minus the guns we love
him it's really nice tim we love your
work in the crew tom thank god for
judicial watch irl kicks ass ps
democracy in peril equals democrat
mandates who says i don't own firearms
but thank you very much i'm glad that
you love me
all right let's grab some
brown bear says who the hell is neil
young
[Laughter]
all of the young people who watch the
show just went who more like neil old
bro yeah no one knows who you are that's
the thing to consider too when we're
like yo neil young is issuing an
ultimatum anyone under like 30 went
who i remember i'm under 30. yeah i know
who he was you've never heard neil young
before that's true i've never i don't
even know once i've heard old man i like
your good songs yeah he's rock he's got
the rock he's got ohio he's got rocket
rocking in the free world i think too
crosby stills nash and young i mean but
when neil left the band it was just
crosby stills and nash and they were
never even held a candle to what the
four of those guys did yeah well
neil young i see this move and i'm just
like it makes me feel that everything
he's ever said has been a lie just to
pander to people to sell albums
one i don't i still think he's legit but
i think he's just gone he's just in he's
like in a computer program on repeat
luke still believes in neil and he's
afraid of covid you heard it here yeah
all right i believe ptsd
prep that says hey tim did you hear
about tiffany cross on msnbc she
actually told people to get weapons and
fight in a war she's trying to get
people to physically harm people for
their opinions and choices
i think she was being metaphorical
you know she was like we are in a war
and people need to you know she said she
made that statement i'm going to be very
careful here but i'll tell you this
it doesn't matter if it was metaphorical
or not
she actually said on msnbc that people
should take up weapons
joe i'm sorry alex jones got banned for
that that's one of the reasons he got
banned because he had made metaphorical
statements about you know fighting back
and defending yourself and stuff like
that so
you know there's a it's it's a two it's
there's two rules here so jen sackey was
like go go to the weekend drink a
margarita come back on monday and let's
fight and i know it's a metaphor class
you said she said take a kickboxing
class then she said you have a margarita
then she said come back on monday and
fight like you're gonna tell people to
come fight is that not inciting yes that
wasn't that caused the president of the
united states to be impeached it's this
metaphor fight fight fight you hear
elizabeth warren we're going to fight
for rights and fight and fight fight
fight you're like dude this is annoying
metaphor it's it's bland you obviously
don't mean to take up physical arms or
why are you saying fights
but it's a metaphor that can get you
banned on youtube if you say it
depending on your political views if tim
said we're not going to take it anymore
they'd probably construe that as a
threat yeah if i if i got up and went
i'm mad as hell and i'm not gonna take
it anymore they'd be like whoa whoa shut
it down what are you implying yeah yeah
what are you implying i don't like the
fight metaphor especially these
politicians using it to rile people up i
don't like it if i came out and said i
want to rock and roll all night and
party every day they'd just be like oh
shut it down
when he had a blade behind him and a
firearm on the wall
someone suggested you get a cutlass so
it's true form
yeah that's a model sword yeah it means
i went to the mall yeah and i went to
some like the cheap guy who was like you
want to buy an asian sword and i was
like they said that the sword cheapens
the gun or that replica so that you
could get a cutlass and make the full
pirate theme i thought that's kind of
neat
i literally was looking on the room like
what can i put behind me and i'm like i
have a mall sword and i have this this
this flint lock
you know
and that's all that happened beautiful
and then we actually had a different
decor yeah we had a different guitar
behind me but it was too bright so we
put up the brett mason that dude is
legit and incredible guitarist wow this
this guitar is red too that dude's this
was awesome all right let's see we got
here we got the world says
why don't we adjust why don't we just
allow debtors to file for bankruptcy
student loans are the only loans where
you can't file for bankruptcy
yeah i don't know if that's true yeah
well also you can't repossess a degree
which is part of it i'm not saying that
there isn't a massive issue with student
loans in the interest payments right now
but
it's a very different differently
structured you used to be able to
default george bush junior he passed
some legislation and he couldn't default
on that there is a massive issue we have
adults making poor financial decisions
and expecting taxpayers to come in and
bail them out and they're seeking a
massive transfer of wealth from people
who don't go to college to people who do
it's elitism in the worst way it is
under the highest income learners in the
country yeah i think there's truth in
that because i do believe the system is
corrupt exactly we stopped we stopped
these loans it's a it's a federal
government program it's it's it's
generate it's
it's
supported by the government exactly when
it happened without government support
yeah exactly well no i mean according to
the national bureau for economic
research the entire reason you have this
student loan crisis and the entire
reason college is so expensive is
because of the wide availability of easy
money so i agree with you there and it
would be an incredibly regressive tax to
you know quote-unquote forgive student
loans but at the same time the idea of
somebody
paying off
significantly more than they ever took
out having paid off their debt and still
having thousands and thousands of
thousands of dollars left i think is
insane standard interest
could you could do away with that
standard interest all right nick zilla
says i don't see how this is a backfire
for neil young read his actual statement
he got what he asked for he's crazy
about audio quality and has hated
spotify since forever being off spotify
is probably worth it to him regardless
of any rogan feelings that's what i'm
talking about no he he wanted to take
his music off because of quality but
then later i guess he said something
like this is the this is the place where
people are getting their music and he
wants people to hear his music so he's
going to stay on the platform
i genuinely believe in my opinion i i
think it's a fair point absolutely
because neil said take me off let's take
off rogan so they did so he got what he
asked for but i genuinely believe he
thought it was gonna be this moment
where these other artists would be like
we're with neil young yeah yay and then
spotify would be like i guess we got to
get rid of joe rogan and then joe would
be like oh
and then they would all high five each
other instead spotify was like
uh
uh bye neil have a nice day joe
increased the value of their company by
like 10 times by joining that platform
the stock skyrocketed it's crazy i don't
know exactly the day after they
announced it was like boom
so yeah they're
not raymond g stanley jr says crenshaw
said he couldn't live off of 175
thousand dollars a year
wow
really i mean you need to say that on
that one man i it feels like dan
crenshaw's been
like just getting a lot of heat as of
like kind of just
not doing well it's insane yeah uh we
are we are going to have dan crenshaw on
the show at some point we are and i
think that'll be uh it'll be fascinating
i think i've done a good job sir luke
will be back for that i would be in
favor of kicking up the salaries for
members of congress as part of my reform
agenda you know you get people in here
for 10 years and what happens is you
have
uh
government is designed to let people who
work in government
prosper but normal people
that they're not welcome in government
and the salaries reflect that so someone
who once who's a businessman or just
starting out you know young a young
person in their career you know the idea
they'd come to congress they couldn't
afford to do it why don't we make it why
don't we make it affordable to someone
to come here for a few years and leave
ben franklin suggested that we pay them
nothing and that everyone has to do it
like they i think only rich people would
do it then well you don't really now in
the modern age you don't have to move to
dc to be serving in congress necessarily
you could read the bills and vote online
yeah i think that's unfortunately a
negative yeah i think people need to be
there to vote look what marjorie taylor
green said they don't even show up so
now you got you you should have to show
up oh i don't know we got we got a very
important one they don't want people
coming to the capitol anymore they don't
right pelosi basically said don't come
this is a a horrible gamer says tim you
lie
what the trespassing the swatting was
all an elaborate plan to scare luke to
gtfo to florida so you can bring in
shame musts
luke's seat is still warm tim
i'm not even gonna you know that person
it sounds uniquely personal was that you
there are a lot of super chat there are
many people who are obsessed with me on
the internet who create rumors and lies
to make me look bad none of that is true
i'm not on trial i got to be honest i'm
not on trial i got to tell them the
truth i'm not on trial
it's time it's time we told him the
truth tim tim sheamus and i colluded
this whole thing stop it what are you
doing it's not scary don't listen to him
he's crazy
tim's crazy what money can i offer you
what are you talking about tim
sheamus is the one who actually got me
the anthony fauci bobblehead we launched
it through ian so that luke wouldn't
know jamis actually asked me to come out
here in the first place after years ago
how did this turn into so many things i
never did cut your hair what am i
delilah you have a nice haircut by the
way thank you i pointed that out
with that we're turning it back around
it started with accusations sorry now
i am getting confident thank you yeah i
appreciate that you know when i was
waiting for someone to notice shame on
the super chats i thought i looked very
nice i was excited for compliments for
my my my adoring fans and you guys
didn't see scale on 110 how beautiful is
sheamus let me know
they're saying they're all putting a one
i'm just kidding they didn't have time
to respond tim all right all right all
right uh
joel seberg says i'm a cdl driver and
have many skills let me know if you need
help please i'm also adept in
construction and farming i see it 10.
well actually um with the new trailer
that we're we're building for the mobile
shows we're planning on going down to
florida to meet back up with luke for
one of our mobile shows we did this in
austin it was amazing and it was one of
the
funniest shows we've ever done it's like
alex jones joe rogan blair white drew
hernandez ian me luke
and uh who who am i forgetting is that
michael melville you know
did forget i forgot the guy sitting next
to me yeah no we we were like james
don't tell don't no one tell them and we
all at a party
i didn't think he's gonna be able to
come on the show because he had his own
show but he was like i can stop by and
then it was just funny when he was like
i i show up to a trailer on the side of
the road like
i'm like yup
that's us
literally exit two yeah from yeah
exactly
from joe's nice podcast studio there's
like stars on the ceiling and like
shooting stars it's crazy it's amazing
to a trailer on the side of the road
where it's like everyone's yelling at
each other and he's like
we're thinking it we're hoping we can do
that with a daily wire crew for sure are
you going to not invite me to that
either tim yeah
go hang out
we're going to get there and seamus is
going to wake up it's going to be like
he's going to walk around like rubbing
his eyes and he's like no one's home is
this home alone yes is this every single
fact because that's what happened last
time except i was at my apartment i
wasn't even i was nowhere near we're in
nashville i was nowhere near tim but i
was still offended i wasn't i think it's
only like nine hours from here or
something but um we talked to them about
it and we might be able to set up our
studio in one of their lots because we
have the big mobile fifth wheel we have
a new one where redesign is gonna be
amazing and then it would actually be
really cool to do we want to do like one
of each of their hosts you know every
night and maybe do one big night with a
bunch of the daily wire people all at
once it would be really fun i wouldn't
invite knowles to something like that no
not him no he's a mess he's a mess yeah
i want to do a theology debate at some
point with sheamus and michael knowles
and we've had some other brilliant
catholics and christians and other just
i don't know about knowles but i
appreciate the compliment no i mean
honestly knowles is knowles is uh i i
hate to compliment him he's a smart guy
i'd love to uh hey shout out to matt
walsh on dr phil too that was great dude
shout out to the daily wire for st
catholic political commentators they're
crushing it oh yeah ben
shapiro you took a mega risk
and jeremy yeah
nice job guys they won
they did and they won all right we got
one more right here it's an important
one
mike says convoy to ottawa is going to
be a huge story need to get on that
story store shelves are beginning to
empty convoy is 3 000 plus trucks over
50 miles long
absolutely men so we'll be digging in
into that stuff but don't forget to
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show wherever you can
share with all your friends that's our
marketing budget we don't got billboards
we're not in airports none of that
youtube propping us up we're actually
swimming against the current and if you
like what we do please share and go to
timcast.com become a member we are going
to have a members only segment we're
going to talk about elections and stuff
so you're not going to want to miss this
one over at timcast.com you can follow
the show at tim cast irl basically
everywhere you can follow me on twitter
instagram or whatever at tim cast tom
you want to shout anything out
judicialwatch.org judicialwatch.org
we're everywhere else but i mean you can
actually look at the documents we're
talking about so and they can help you
you guys are a non-profit we are they
can you can support by getting the word
out and obviously directly donating to
us are you guys a 501c3 or yes we are a
charity 501c3 yes so tax deductible tax
deductible you go to the full extent of
the law there it is right on absolutely
you got any social media you want to
mention yeah i'm at tom fitton judicial
watches all over and you know i'm on all
the places now right uh sheamus do you
sell t-shirts no i actually um yeah
freedomtunesmarch.com i guess i just oh
you do sell t-shirts yeah yeah uh
so i do uh tim thank you
and oh yeah if you guys want to check
those out i so and also
i um
i have a youtube channel oh it's called
freedom tunes if you guys want to check
that out uh t-o-o-n-s and we uploaded a
video yesterday poking some fun at
tucker carlson and the whole eminem
debacle and tomorrow we're gonna be
doing a cartoon uh we're gonna be
releasing one parodying the idea of
forcing children to wear masks in
schools i think you guys are gonna love
it go over there subscribe the line from
bernie in your latest video this is bolt
this is one of the best thank you so
much thank you so much you guys also
follow me ian crossland.net uh check my
socials out there i also have a youtube
channel subscribe to me on youtube i
made a video yesterday the first time in
a while talking about the scientific
modeling methods and some flaws i think
there are in it so if you want to see
that check it out on youtube and i will
see you soon
thank you guys for tuning in this
evening please do share the video and
tell all your friends about us and get
everybody involved in this and try to
change the culture and make a difference
in the world you guys may follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlids
we will see you all over at timcast.com
become a member to support our work and
you will see these special uncensored
segments thanks for hanging out we'll
see y'all there bye guys
you